thank you
foreign
so
good
thank you
good morning dear colleagues can I ask
you to take your seats
good morning
I am very pleased
this morning
to welcome the president of the European
commission can I please ask you
to take your seats for this
important occasion
I am very pleased to welcome the
president of
the European commission Ursula
Wonderland to our European Parliament
for the annual state of the European
Union Address
over the last years we have
overcome
a financial crisis a pandemic
we have gone through brexit and found
new ways forward we have stood up and
stood firm
against Russia's illegal and brutal
invasion of Ukraine we are addressing
the climate emergency we have disengaged
from toxic Russian energy and we have
set the foundation for years to come the
European union today is stronger and
more united than ever before
the world is changing and Europe must
adapt and change with it too we must
keep striving to make our place our
Europe a place of equality of
opportunity of access of
Prosperity where everyone can reach
their potential we must keep reforming
so we have come
a long way but even so too many people
across
our Union are still struggling through
many women still face unfair barriers
too many of our young people still face
an uncertain future we need to keep our
people's concerns at the center of all
our actions and to underline how we will
do that it is truly my pleasure
to introduce the president of the
European commission to deliver
her 2023 state of the European Union
address which for the first time I am
extremely proud to say will be
interpreted in international sign
language
the floor is yours
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam president
ministers
honorable members
in just under 300 days
Europeans will take to the polls in our
unique and remarkable democracy
as with any election it will be the time
for people to reflect on the state of
our Union
and the work done by those that
represent them
but it will also be a time to decide on
what kind of future
and what kind of Europe they want
among them will be millions of
first-time voters
the youngest of them
were born in 2008 the economic and
financial crisis
as they stand in that polling Booth they
will think about what matters to them
they will think about the war that rages
at our borders
or the impact of destructive climate
change
about how artificial intelligence will
influence their lives
or their chances of getting a house
or job in the years ahead
our union today reflects the vision of
those who dreamed of a better future
after World War II
a future in which a union of Nations
democracies and people
work together to share peace and
prosperity
they believe that Europe was the answer
to the call of History
and when I speak to the new generation
of young people today
I see that same vision for a better
future
that same burning desire to build
something better
that same belief that in a world of
uncertainty
Europe once again must answer the call
of History
and that is what we have to do together
this starts with earning the trust of
Europeans
to deal with aspirations and anxieties
and in the next 300 days we must finish
the job that they entrusted us with
I want to thank this house
for its leading role in delivering on
the most ambitious Transformations this
Union has ever embarked on
when I stood in front of you in 2019
with my program for green a digital and
geopolitical Europe
I know that some had doubts
and that was before the world turned
upside down with a global pandemic and a
brutal war on European soil
but look at where Europe is today
we've seen the births of a geopolitical
union supporting Ukraine
standing up to Russia's aggression
responding to an assertive China
Investing in Partnerships
we now have now have a European green
deal as a centerpiece of our economy and
unmatched inhibition
we have set the path for digital
transition to become Global Pioneers in
online rights
we have the historic Next Generation EU
combining 800 billion euros of
investment and reform
and creating decent jobs for today and
tomorrow
we have set the building blocks for a
health union
helping to vaccinate an entire continent
and large parts of the world
we've started making ourselves more
independent
in critical sectors like energy chips
and raw materials
I would also like to thank you
for the ground breaking and pioneering
work we did on gender equity
as a woman
this means a lot to me
we've concluded files that many thought
would be blocked forever
like the woman on boards directive
and the historic accession of the EU to
the Istanbul convention
with the directive on paid transparency
we have cast into law the basic
principle
that equal work deserves equal pay
there is not a single argument why for
the same type of work a woman should be
paid less than a man
but our work
is far from over
and we must continue pushing for
Progress together
I know this house supports our proposal
on combating violence against women
and here too
I would like that we cast into law
another basic principle
no means no
there can be no true equality without
freedom from violence
and thanks to this Parliament
to member states and to my team of
Commissioners
we have delivered over 90 percent of the
political guidelines I presented in
2019.
together we have shown that when Europe
is bold and United
it gets things done
and our work is far from over so let's
Stand Together
let's deliver today and prepare for
tomorrow
honorable members
four years ago
the European green deal was our answer
to the call of History
and this summer
the hottest ever on record in Europe was
a stark reminder of that
Greece and Spain were struck by ravaging
wildfires
and were hit again only a few weeks
later by devastating flood
and we saw the chaos and Carnage of
extreme weather from Slovenia to
Bulgaria and right across our Union
this is the reality of a boiling planet
European green deal was born out of this
necessity
to protect our planet
but it was also designed as an
opportunity
to preserve our future prosperity
we started this mandate by setting
long-term perspective with the climate
law and the 2050 goals
we shifted the climate agenda to being
an economic one
and this has given clear sense of
direction
for investment and innovation
and we have already seen this gross
strategy delivering in the short term
Europe's industry is showing every
single day that it is ready to power
this transition
proving that modernization
and decarbonization can go hand in hand
in the last five years the number of
clean steel factories in the European
Union has grown from zero
to 38.
we're now attracting more investment in
clean hydrogen than the United States
and China together
and tomorrow I will be in Denmark with
prime minister Mata Frederickson to see
that Innovation firsthand
we will Mark the launch of the first
container ship
powered by Clean methanol made with
solar energy
this is the strength of Europe's
response to climate change
the European green deal provides the
necessary frame incentives and
investment but it is the people the
innovators the inventors the engineers
who develop the solutions
and this is why honorable members
as we enter the next phase of the
European green deal one thing will never
change
we will keep supporting European
industry throughout this transition they
can rely on that
we started with a package of measures
from The Net Zero industry act to the
critical raw materials Act
with our industry strategy
we're looking at the risks and needs of
each ecosystem in this transition and we
need to finish this work
and with this
we need to develop an approach for each
industrial ecosystem
therefore
starting from this month
we will hold a series of clean
transition dialogues with industry
the core aim will be to support every
sector
in building its business model for the
decarbonization of Industry
because we believe that this transition
is essential for our future
competitiveness in Europe
and this is just as much about the
people and their jobs today
our wind industry for instance is a
European success story
but it is currently facing a unique mix
of challenges
and this is why we will put forward a
European wind power package working
closely with industry and member states
we will Fast Track permitting even more
we will improve the auction systems
across the European Union we will focus
on skills access to finance and stable
Supply chains
but this is broader than just one sector
from wind to Steel from batteries to
electric vehicles
our ambition is crystal clear
the future of our clean tech industry
has to be made in Europe this is our
task
honorable members this shows that when
it comes to the European green deal we
stay the course
we stay ambitious and we stick to our
growth strategy
and we will always strive for fair and
just transition
that means a fair outcome for future
generations to live on a healthy planet
a fair drawing Journey for all those
impacted with decent jobs and the solemn
promise to leave no one behind
just think about manufacturing jobs and
competitiveness the topic we're
discussing a lot in these days
our Industries and tech companies like
competition they know that Global
competition is good for business
and that it creates and protects jobs
here in Europe
but competition is only true as long as
it is fair
too often our companies are excluded
from farm markets
or are victims of predatory practices
they are often undercut by competitors
benefiting from huge State subsidies
we have not forgotten how China's unfair
Trade Practices affected our solar
industry
many young businesses were pushed out by
heavily subsidized Chinese competitors
pioneering companies had to file for
bankruptcies
promising talents when searching for
Fortune abroad
this is
why fairness in the global economy
is so important because it affects lives
and livelihoods
entire Industries and communities depend
on it
so we have to be clear-eyed about the
risks we face
take the electric vehicle sector
it is a crucial industry for the clean
economy with a huge potential in Europe
but Global markets are now flooded with
cheaper Chinese electric cars
and their price is kept artificially Low
by huge State subsidies
this is distorting our Market
and as we do not accept this Distortion
from the inside in our Market
we do not accept this from the outside
so I can announce today
that the commission is launching an
anti-subsidy investigation into electric
vehicles coming from China
Europe is open to competition
but not for race to the bottom we must
defend ourselves against unfair
practices
but equally it is vital to keep open
lines of communication and dialogue with
China
because there are also topics where we
can and have to cooperate
de-risk not decouple
this will be my Approach
with the Chinese leadership as the at
the EU China Summit later this year
ladies and gentlemen
in the European Union
we are proud
of our cultural diversity
we are a Europe of the regions
we have a unique blend of languages
music art Traditions crafts
cuisines
and we are also a Europe which is a
continent of unique biological diversity
about 6 500 species which are only found
in Europe nowhere else in the world
in northern northern Europe we have the
world natural heritage site that wasn't
sea which is a unique habitat offering a
home to rare species of Flora and Fauna
and it's a vital resource for millions
of migratory Birds
and with the Baltic we have the largest
area of brackish water in the world and
south of that we have the European Plain
we have vast tracts of more land and
Wetland that characterizes that plane
these regions are important allies
against climate change
protected Moors and wetlands absorb huge
volumes of greenhouse gases they secure
Regional water cycles
and they are home to a unique
biodiversity as well
we have
a Europe that is a continent of forests
with the mighty coniferous forests of
the north and east
the last remnants of Virgin Oak and
Beach forests in Central Europe to the
Cork Oak Forest of southern Europe
all of these forests are irreplaceable
as a source of goods and services they
absorb carbon dioxide they supply wood
and indeed other products they generate
fertile soils they filter the air the
water
biodiversity and ecosystem services are
absolutely essential for all of us in
Europe
the loss of nature doesn't only destroy
the foundations of our life but also the
feeling of what people consider home
that is something we must protect
[Applause]
thank you
and at the same time
we have to make sure that food security
is in harmony with nature
that remains an essential task and today
I'd like to express my appreciation to
our farmers
[Applause]
my appreciation and my gratitude that
day by day they are always providing
food for us and producing healthy food
of course is the fundamental task of our
agricultural policy the task of
Agriculture and self-sufficiency in food
is also important for us
that is something that our farmers are
providing
it's not an easy task
because the consequences of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine climate
change bringing droughts forest fires
and flooding but also new obligations
are all having a growing impact on
Farmers work and Farmers incomes and we
must bear this in mind
many are already working hard towards a
more sustainable form of agriculture we
need to work together with the farmers
and people working in agriculture to
tackle these new challenges and that's
the only way we can secure a supply of
food for the future for all of us so we
need more dialogue we need less
polarization
and hence we would like to launch a
strategic Dialogue on the future of
agriculture in the EU
I am and remain convinced that
Agriculture and protection of our
natural world can go hand in hand we
need both
[Applause]
honorable members of fair transition for
Farmers families and Industry
this is the Hallmark of this mandate
and it is all the more important as we
Face strong economic headwinds
I see three major economic challenges
for our industry in the year ahead
labor and skill challenges
inflation
and making business easier for our
companies
the first has to do with our labor
market we have not forgotten the early
days of the global pandemic when
everyone predicted a new wave of 1930s
style mass unemployment
but we defied this prediction
we're sure
the first ever European short time work
initiative
we saved 40 million jobs
this is and was
Europe's social market economy in action
and I think we can be proud of it
we then immediately restarted our
economic engine thanks to Next
Generation EU and today we see the
results
Europe is close to full employment
instead of millions of people looking
for jobs
millions of jobs are looking for people
labor and skill shortages are reaching
record levels both here and across all
major economies
74 percent of smes are saying they are
facing skill shortages
in the peak of the tourist season
restaurants and bars in Europe are
reducing
their hours because they cannot find the
staff they need
hospitals are postponing treatments
because lack of nurses and doctors
and two-thirds of European companies are
looking for I.T Specialists two-thirds
at the same time millions of parents
mostly mothers are struggling to
reconcile work and family because there
is no appropriate child care
and eight million young people are
neither in employment nor in education
nor in training 8 million the dreams put
on hold their lives on standby
this is not only the cause of so much
personal distress
it is also one of the most significant
bottlenecks
of our competitiveness
because labor shortages hamper the
capacity for Innovation growth and
prosperity
so we need to improve access to the
labor market
most importantly for young people
for women
and we need qualified migration
in addition we need to respond to the
Deep rooted shifts in technology society
and demography
and for that we should rely on the
expertise of business and trade unions
our collective bargaining partners
it is almost 40 years ago
meeting
that saw the birth
of European social dialogue
since then social Partners have shaped
the union of today
ensuring progress and prosperity for
Millions
and as the world around changes faster
than ever social Partners must again be
at the heart of the future
together
we must focus on the challenges facing
the labor market from skills and labor
shortages to New Challenges like AI
this is why
together with the Belgian presidency
next year
we will convene a new social partner
Summit once again at waldushes
the future of Europe will be built with
and by the social Partners this is our
task
the second major economic challenge
persistent High inflation Christine
Lagarde and the European Central Bank
are working hard to keep inflation under
control
we know that returning to the ecb's
medium-term Target will take some time
the good news is that Europe has started
bringing Energy prices down
we have not forgotten Putin's deliberate
use of gas as a weapon
and how it triggered fears of blackout
and an energy crisis like in the 70s
many thought we would not make it
through the winter because of lack of
energy
but we made it
we made it because we stayed United
pooling our demand and buying energy
together
and at the same time and different to
the 70s
we use this crisis to massively invest
in renewable energy and Fast Track the
clean transition
we used Europe's critical mass to bring
prices down and secure our supply
just take this the price for gas in
Europe was over 300 Euros per megawatt
hour one year ago
it is now around 35 300 today 35.
so we need to look at how we can
replicate this model of power purchasing
power at the market a model of success
also in other fields like critical raw
materials and for example clean hydrogen
the third challenge
of European companies is about making it
easier to do business
small companies do not have the capacity
to cope with complex Administration
or they are held back by lengthy
processes
this often means
they do less with the time they have
and that they miss out on opportunities
to grow
this is why
before the end of the year
we will appoint an EU SME Envoy
reporting directly to me
we want to hear directly from small
admittees to ensure AI develops in a
human-centric transparent and
responsible way
and this is why in my political
guidelines I committed to setting out a
legislative approach in the first 100
days
you remember we put forward the AI Act
the world's first
comprehensive pro-innovation AI law
and I want to thank this house and the
council for the Tyler's work on this
groundbreaking law
our AI Act is already a blueprint for
the whole work we must now focus on
adopt adopting the rules as soon as
possible and turn to implementation
the second pillar is governance
we are now laying the foundation for a
single governance system in Europe
but we should also join forces with our
partners to ensure a global approach
to understanding the impact of AI on our
societies
now since think about the invaluable
contribution of the ipcc for climate
this is a global panel
that provides the latest science to
policy makers
I believe we need a similar body for AI
on the risks and on its benefits for
Humanity
yes we're scientists but also tech
companies and independent experts all
around the world
this will allow us to develop a fast and
globally coordinated response
building on the work done by the
Hiroshima process and others
and the third pillar is guiding
innovation in a responsible way
thanks to our investment in the last
years Europe has now become a leader in
super computing
with three
out of the five most powerful
supercomputers in the world
so we need to capitalize on that
and this is why I can announce today a
new initiative
to open up our high performance
computers to AI startups that gives them
the opportunity to train their models
but in a responsible way
but this will honestly be one part of
our work to guide innovation
what we need is an open dialogue with
those that develop and deploy AI
this dialogue happens already in the
United States as you know seven major
tech companies have already agreed to
voluntary rules around safety security
and Trust
it happens here where we will work on AI
companies with AI companies
so that they voluntarily commit to the
principles of the AI act B4 it enters in
two Force because we cannot lose time
anymore
so now we should bring all of this work
together
towards minimum Global standards for
safe and ethical use of AI our people
deserve it
honorable members when I stood here four
years ago I said that if we are united
in the inside nobody will divide us from
The Outsider and this was the thinking
behind the geopolitical commission
our team Europe approach
has enabled us to be more strategic more
assertive and more united and that is
more important than ever
our heart bleeds when we see the
devastating loss of life in Libya and
Morocco
after the violent floods and earthquake
Europe will always stand ready to
support in any way we can
or think about the Sahel region
one of the poorest yes yet fastest
growing demographically
the succession of military coups will
make the region more unstable for years
ahead
Russia is both influencing and
benefiting from the crisis
and the region has become fertile ground
to the rise of terrorism
this is of direct concern for Europe for
security and our prosperity
so we need to show the same Unity of
purpose towards Africa as we have shown
towards Ukraine this is a must
we need to focus on cooperation with
legitimate governments and Regional
organizations
we need to develop a mutually beneficial
partnership which focuses on common
issues for Europe and Africa
and this is why together with hrvp
borrel
we will work on a new strategic approach
to take forward at the new at the next
euau Summit
honorable members Histories on the move
Russia is waging a full-scale war
against the founding principles of the
UN Charter
this has raised immense concerns in
countries from Central Asia
to the indo-pacific they are worried
that in a law less World they might face
the same fate as Ukraine
we see a clear attempt by some to return
to block thinking
trying to isolate and influence
countries in between
and it comes at a time when there is a
deeper unease by many emerging economies
about the way
institutions and globalization work for
them
these concerns are legitimate
these emerging economies with its people
and natural assets
are essential allies in building a
cleaner safer and more prosperous world
so Europe will always work with them to
reform and improve the International
System
we want to lead efforts
to make the rules-based order fairer and
make distribution more equal
this will also mean working with and not
the smugglass decides who can enter into
Europe
we welcome
we welcome that's why the moratorium of
understanding between the European Union
and Tunisia we must work with our
neighbors to solve the challenges like
we did it also in the past with turkey
and we must finalize the migration pact
it's a unique even historic opportunity
to give a proper answer now it's in our
high ends let's do it I count again on
the fund the line maturity to achieve
this
and the third point I want to mention
what's next for our European project 25
years ago
the Euro was born despite many who
criticized him Helmut Cole had a vision
for Europe
what is the Euro of today what is our
project first
Ukraine must win the war and yes was
Allah the merit-based approach of
enlargement process is key to our
approach towards Western Balkans Moldova
and Ukraine we have to keep our promises
but we need to go further
the gaspari already knew what is needed
for a good future that is why he burst
into tears when they told him in 1945
for 54 that the European Defense
Community was rejected
I think you have to come back to the
gaspari's idea we need a European
Defense Union as a defense commissioner
joined European forces on land sea and
air by 2030 and all this embedded into a
strengthened NATO as a strong European
pillar that is the leading project of
Our Generation we need to lead that the
best medicine against extremists no
fears not fears anger or even hate shall
Define the debate optimism Vision Values
and the Readiness for the next step to
become a real European Union is the
answer that starts today thank you thank
you Mr weather
I now
invite erase Garcia Perez on behalf of
the snd group to take the Vlog five
minutes
president
thank you president
this is the last debate of the
legislature on the state of the union
and it's taking place at a time of
profound change president from the line
commissioners
thank you very much for your capacity
for dialogue and achieving consensus in
the Socialist and Democrats group we are
very proud of having made a contribution
and indeed been in a leadership position
in terms of historic in the context of a
historic decisions that have placed
Europe at the heart of our citizens
the response to the financial crisis in
2008 which was weighed down by the lack
of coordination and the austerity policy
imposed by the right through to the
response to the pandemic and Russia's
war against Ukraine led by social
democracy has been marked by unity and
solidarity our main priority now has to
be to push for re-industrialization to
ensure open strategic autonomy with an
eye on Africa and Latin America
alongside
re-industrialization we must make
progress on the green transition curbing
the effects of legal curbing the effects
of climate change is a legal obligation
and a moral obligation we need to push
forward with the reform of the
electricity Market to accelerate the
deployment of renewable energies and
reduce electricity prices and
Mrs underline in the
face of those who are climate change
deniers we need
to
break the silence and send a clear
message of support for the green deal
and commit to pushing through laws on
nature restoration and air quality
we are going to be
scrutinizing very closely to ensure
that you do indeed follow through on
that to generate wealth and New
Opportunities we need to strengthen the
social pillar
there Mrs funderline I would have
appreciated hearing somewhat more of a
commitment inflation High interest rates
and Rising mortgages hinder a fair life
project
public housing is a right rather than as
a commodity for speculation
equality and employment abandon unpaid
internships a minimum living wage and an
anti-poverty strategy with binding
targets must become a reality
we must also protect women who suffer
gender-based violence Mrs Wonderland
I share
your view that no means no of course now
the time has come to take a step further
and to incorporate violence against
women
in the European Union's list of crimes
we must not give up on our fight for
social justice because social cohesion
not only dignifies people's lives but
also allows us to act with a voice and
wait in the world today we United in the
face of an aggressor Putin is a war
criminal who will spend his long train
we are united but let us not be
complacent the time has come to
strengthen the unity of the European
Union to make it more flexible so that
we streamline decision-making processes
by moving towards qualified majority
voting we must also continue to support
the other countries in our neighborhood
who want to unite their Destiny with
that of the European Union and while
tackling the main challenges we need to
find solutions to other challenges that
will Mark the future of the European
Union The Pact on migration and Asylum
to avoid the loss of human lives in the
Mediterranean
Mrs Van Der Lyon
European taxpayers money should not be
ending up in the pockets of governments
who are undermining the fundamental
rights of persons
we need a permanent fiscal capacity to
face future crises the reform of tax
rules and greater tax Justice
to make an economy that is not only more
competitive but
also fairer
business profits must be used to improve
the living conditions of ordinary people
to many not the few ladies and gentlemen
we live in the European Union a life
project that has built the best place
for democracy rights equality and
solidarity today the alliance between
the right and the far right represents
the resounding failure of a Project
based on involution Mr Weber you have
made an historic mistake and history
will
remember you you cannot call
on this majority talk about a majority
with thunder line and then Chase votes
uh chasing other alliances in this
chamber
there is no going back we will continue
to build a prosperous open and inclusive
Union a union proud of its plurality and
diversity a union that Embraces the rule
of law
a union will United and stronger in the
fact for equality social justice and
Union of Tolerance and progress there is
always time for a dream 70 years ago
Europe dreamed of a better future and
made it a reality today for another year
we are living that dream let us continue
making it a reality thank you very much
to the president of the renew group
for four minutes
thank you madam president Madam
president ladies and gentlemen this
plenary session on the state of the
union is not just like any other it's
the last one of the turn of office it's
the last one before the European
elections and you said it Madam
president these last four years have
been
some of the most remarkable years in the
European Union construction and renew
Europe has been
proud to have been useful has been
assumed responsibility during this
period
has brought together pro-europeans in
good faith I'd like to thank the groups
we work with majorities sometimes
different majorities sometimes more left
more right
some with the vandalion format with
criticism I've noted from my colleague
but we've always made progress
made progress in a coordinated fashion
to help Europe
so in a nutshell looking at the Spirit
of my group we're proud of our joint
achievements and we hope that these
final months will prove useful in the
fashion of the last four years but
renews quite clear on some of the
priorities as well some of the
priorities of my group haven't been
taken to if I can start with a positive
aspects I think Europe has proved itself
more useful for fellow citizens than
ever before but before it
said that it was present for the
pandemic it was present to face up to
aggression of Russia and Ukraine and
uniting Europeans
we have the European green deal which it
makes Europe the an exemplary continent
when it comes to the environmental
transition
um we don't need to be ashamed of what
we achieved on the ecology and the
environment I don't think any
parliamentary chamber in the world has
achieved such courageous and ambitious
decisions as we have
we stand up for our workers our
companies the re-industrialization of
our continent is now something it's been
triggered it's happening to help our own
sovereignty our jobs our purchasing
power
and we're there for our fellow citizens
and their rights the digital Wild West
is being tamed we have European laws to
do that we're going to have specific
legislation brought in
for the independent of the media and we
are working on collective security
founded on a common defense and the
things that need to be taken to the
Natural conclusion the green deal is one
of those things something that remains
to be done you said Madam President we
need to find a sustainable solution for
issues on my
which we need to have a European
industrial answer over the past nine
well sorry in the nine last months we
have before the elections we need to
work together on that and
I hope that my group will be hurt
because being useful isn't just a
question having regulation for
regulations sake or legislation for
legislation's sake we have to reduce
bureaucracy for our citizens and
companies but we also need to make sure
that we're investing in a way that will
achieve our uh objectives it has to be
commensurate with those objectives and
the green and digital transitions are
important but they need to be
underpinned with laws that are simple
comprehensible and well financed so
Madam president to conclude there's a
subject that my group gets angry about
sometimes and that is the defense of our
Democratic model
I welcome the work done by the
commissioner
and turning to the council as well as
co-legis later we know that sometimes
there have been some feat dragging
amongst the heads of state and
government and the Europeans don't
always meet the expectations of uh
heeding the calls from our polish judges
our Hungarian judges independent press
and Civil Society my Italian prosecutors
changed the entries in the Civil
registry of children because their
mothers happen to be lesbian
my group has called for more efficiency
more Simplicity more reforms it has
always done that we think that unanimity
is a poison it's toxic if you imagine
the degree of our support for Ukraine is
dependent on Victor Orban
Madam President we refuse the toppling
of Europe we refuse the organization of
our continent it's a real danger not
just in political terms but also in
economic and social terms
there's an endemic risk of corruption a
risk of whole communities being targeted
and that runs counter to our European
DNA I would say even it runs counter to
the whole plan we have for our very
civilization in Europe
Madam president you wanted a
geopolitical commission you mentioned
that in your speech and it has I think
in the course of history been much more
than that but democracy is very rarely
die because of exterior exterior threats
they die because of internal threats
thank you very much for your speech we
share most of what you've said and I
hope these last nine months of alleged
proved to be useful to the court
president of the the green group
Philip Lambert's for six and a half
minutes
dear president from the line their
colleagues it's not without emotion
having been in this Parliament for 14
years that I'm taking part today in my
last state of the union debate
for 10 years I witnessed to European
Union blinded by economic Orthodoxy
death to the Social and climate
emergencies
but 2019 Market the turning point
for the first time in its history
European Union made the fight against
climate change a top priority
and Against All Odds the European green
deal with stood the pandemic and the war
that rocked the European Union
each time it was put front and center in
all response
we are very much of this to you madam
president to your vision your
persistence and your leadership
unsurprisingly those who never embraced
the European green deal in the first
place are now calling for a pause a
moratorium to weaken its ambition
in the name of protecting your
competitiveness if you see what I mean
to them I say this
we are not above nature
humanity is part of nature whether we
like it or not there are limits to what
our planet can take and to what it can
give
respecting those limits is not the
Green's hobby horse it is a question of
survival
and this struggle for survival all too
many European citizens are now seeing
firsthand
can you imagine a Greek firefighter
walking away from the Raging Inferno or
rescue worker when floods hit Slovenia
say let's take it easy no
they are giving everything they have to
get these climate events under control
we owe it to them and to every citizen
caught up in the extremes and live by
climate change to act with all we have
we have waited for too long
so stand for Madame President we cannot
content ourselves with just implementing
what has already been decided which in
itself is not enough to meet the 1.5
degree roaming Target
so much remains to be done instead of
carbon sinks or Agriculture and
authoritry have become net carbon
emitters or land Water and Air are so
polluted by forever chemicals heavy
metals fine particles Plastics that they
are causing massive deaths and disease
and this leads to a collapsing
biodiversity which endangers all lives
and livelihoods
but as you've said Madam president the
ecological transition is not just a
necessity it is the single biggest
Economic Opportunity for Europe
shine away from it would make us
followers also rants condemned to import
the solutions we need from the rest of
the world
the key to competitiveness to your
colleagues is for economies to embrace
the green transition to support
entrepreneurs who want to lead it and to
ditch the rent Seekers this is so sure
is true to EU prosperity
Politics the political viability of the
European green deal will depend on our
capacity to demand more from those who
have the most and less from those who
have the least
there are limits to what the planet can
take but the same goes for our societies
financial crisis Eurozone crisis
pandemic war in Ukraine energy crisis
every time it's ordinary citizens who
foot the bill whereas those who own
Capital continue to accumulate
even Christine Lagarde said it most of
the current inflammation is due to the
massive increase in corporate profits
president you'll certainly object that
social and fiscal Justice are the remit
of member states and that's true
but given that in the past the European
commission was able to push governments
to adopt unfair reforms it should also
be able to demand that they do what's
right
it does have direct means of action as
well
for example and they're available look
at housing most young people can no
longer afford accommodation in the towns
where they work and the cause Financial
speculation in the property Market the
good news is that Financial regulation
is an EU competence so what are you
waiting for to deal with this highly
charged situation
like nature common goods or energy
housing can't be a simple financial
asset left to the vagaries of the market
we if we want
the environmental transition to be our
unifying project we shouldn't lose sight
of the fact that our Union is first and
foremost a community of values however
everywhere in Europe fundamental
freedoms are in Retreat whether it's
people calling the rights of women into
question the underfunding and co-opting
of just the Judiciary hyperconcentration
of the media spying on journalists
activists and political leaders or
police violence against demonstrators
and people of an ethnic minority
background president in spite of the
legal and financial oppressions that
you've put on two member states the
backsliding continues and is increasing
as guardian of European law the
commission will have to redouble its
efforts for not only vis-a-vis Poland
and Hungary the one that comes first in
Article 2 is human dignity
and there's no greater denial of this
fundamental value than the way we treat
people seeking protection from us
today European Asylum policy boils down
to make Europe a fortress and to rely on
autocrats dictators and failed states to
keep refugees and migrants away from all
shores this has made Smugglers rich and
turned the Mediterranean into a mass
grave
and I'm afraid Madam president I don't
share your optimism the EU backed on
Asylum and migration does not
fundamentally change this deadly logic
or Union as a duty a responsibility and
I would even say a need to take its fair
share in welcoming forcibly displaced
people and it can if we only harness or
Collective capabilities or moral credit
is at stake not least in Africa
for decades the fear of migration has
been instrumentalized by the far right
and now it seems that the fight against
climate change has become their new
Target
but what concerns me even more mad I'm
president is the fact that a growing
number of your party colleagues are
embracing the same strategy the same
language in the whole probably of
bringing voters back into the Epp fault
several Epp member parties are
considering or have chosen to form
coalitions with far-right parties and
some of the representatives were not
even ashamed to admit to me that they
share so much with them in terms of
values and program
so in the name of the greens European
tree Alliance I'm appealing to you don't
let Robert schumann's party drift away
from its values the values on which the
European Union has been founded
[Applause]
colleagues and I'm concluding
the pandemic and the war on a background
of climate disruption persuaded the
majority of our co-citizens that it's
only together that we can tackle the
challenges of this Century the European
Union has regained Credit in their eyes
to the point that those
not very many of them who are calling
for to for their country to leave the
European Union you no longer dare to do
it publicly
we need to stick to our course and
ensure that if the efforts are fairly
distributed that's how we can make our
Union an area of Peace and Freedom with
shared and sustainable Prosperity our
co-citizens and particularly our young
people who are rightly anxious about the
future expect no less from us let's
Kindle and maintain their trust thank
you thank you I give the floor now
the Richard legusko for five minutes on
behalf of the ECR group
Madam president Madam president ladies
and gentlemen is the EU in better shape
today than shall we say 20 years ago the
answer is emphatic no
to paraphrase paraphrase Shakespeare's
hamlets something is rotten in the State
of the Union
there is more than ever instability
conflict tension and uncertainty
let me quote a recent issue of The
Economist
inflation remains hot
officials are increasingly worried by
the Cloudy growth Outlook the block is
facing recession unquote it is to your
credits Madam president that you
initiated and continue the sanctions
against Russia but again one cannot be
all too happy before The Invasion the
commission did not dare to do something
about the German Russian energy Alliance
through this refusal to act the
commission Bears some responsibility for
the depth of the energy crisis
the migration policy has been a failure
despite the commission's hustle and
bustle and fiery rhetoric the people
smuggling business is thriving and the
disintegration of the social fabric
continues
in Western Europe the number of thefts
robberies and rapes has sought about 30
rapes for 100 000 inhabitants in France
and Belgium compared to less than two in
my country
the green deal the commission's flagship
instead of being a vehicle of growth is
a costly Extravaganza over 300 billion
euros by 2030 with Rising living costs
energy bills and other unpleasant
aspects of the commissions and the
parliaments fantasies
the commission has been unsurprisingly
silent on this matter
the last Sinister fantasy is the nature
restoration law
the curator of these harmful Revolution
Mr timmermans has taken a convenient
exit and seeks his luck in National
politics I hope Dutch voters will give
him what he deserves
another Financial Extravaganza has been
the common debt
of 800 billion euros by 2026
we already know the predictions were
erroneous
the cost of all this will be at least
twice as high
the EU budget is in shambles
minus 66 billion euros as of today
you apparently calculated that the
markets would have had more trust in the
financial credibility of the EU than
that of the member states unfortunately
you mistook the EU propaganda for the
real thing
and finally politics
when I compare the past commission with
yours I see a continuous slide towards
oligarchy with a growing disregard for
any restraints the Treatise stipulated
the commission turned into a partisan
machine meddling in National politics
trying to topple the governments they
don't like
you yourself Madam president threatened
the Italian voters before the elections
let me quote you if things go in a
difficult direction we have tools you
said
let me remind you you don't have any
tools to interfere with the Democratic
process of the nation-state Mr ukashenko
has such tools you don't
you
[Applause]
you made you made the rule of lawyer
caricature there is an old proverb
physician heal thyself
heal thyself Madam presidents for one
thing let the commission stop juggling
with the legal basis claiming for
instance that taxes are not taxes but
contributions thus sidestepping the
necessary procedures
and perhaps start by providing all the
documents relevant to the vaccines deal
including the text messages
that would be that would be a good
example of how to be a law abiding
person
and the last point
believe it or not but this commission
will go in history as one that uh
uh try to regulate the language of the
European Union
and to establish a sort of officially
sanctioned indoctrination
for instance by abolishing certain words
such as Christmas
yes you withdrew from this idiotic move
but the fact is that the bureaucrats
were planning it a large bunch of the
European Commission
have been working on how we should speak
and how we should avoid the word
Christmas I mean this is simply
outrageous
so but this gives us an insight into how
the commission works and what we see
should be a warning to us all
I give the floor now to the president of
the ID group marcozani for two and a
half minutes
[Applause]
thank you president
Van Der Lyon
I wasn't expecting fireworks from your
speech it was more of a an election
campaign for you restanding as president
but even so
I find it rather disheartening to note
that the weapons which you talk about as
a response to the crisis that the
citizens of Europe are living through
what you have
your disposal
is rather disappointing Point by point
the green deal
we have a historic
opportunity today to be more pragmatic
and less utopian
with Timmerman's departure you have an
opportunity
to get that transition back on the right
track
starting with the basics
climate change
is an area where the problem isn't the
EU the problem isn't European Farmers
the problem isn't European businesses
the problem isn't
European owners Earth uh premises what
we need to do is look at who will be the
winners of the transition the
environment citizens or will it be China
we need to keep a very close eye on that
you said that it is the commission's
intention to act in relation to this
problem with Research into combating
subsidies in 2023
does the commission really need to
launch an investigation
into that matter
it seems completely clear that China is
engaging in unfair competition my son is
not yet five can see that we need the
commission to do its own job to protect
our businesses
to impose duties on those who do not
respect the rules
the second proposal which you announced
an inquiry into the impact of
bureaucracy I believe for you intending
to nominate a kind of special Envoy who
will be acting as a go between between
you and smes I don't think we need a new
Envoy
everyone in this room the elected
members uh M voice representing people
we don't need more inquiries
into fine words we actually need less
red tape businesses are crying out for
fewer laws better implemented and more
freedom but that appears not to be the
European commission's priority final
Point immigration
we've heard all sorts of plans and
initiatives
but it doesn't appear that the EU really
wants to get to grips with that problem
the weight of migratory flows which is
unsustainable will be borne by a few
countries
the eu's line on this is not clear
it is not clear who has a right to enter
or not enter those who do not have a
right to enter should not enter illegal
immigration
should be considered a crime and
if we don't reduce the number of
arrivals then we cannot resolve the
problem of redistribution I hope that
over the next few months there will be a
change of Direction and we'll be giving
more space to what citizens are calling
out for rather than new pointless mvoice
so I hope that's clear on behalf of the
left group for four minutes
foreign
thank you very much Madam president
our political success cannot be measured
in soapbox oratory
it's measured by the real life
conditions the majority of people
and we've heard about
the man on the moon moment when it comes
to what you're talking about social
justice tax Justice rule of law climate
neutrality respect and dignity there's
all sorts of watchwords you're using
and basically you are promising
Europeans everything under the sun
but in reality is very different
a simple worker in the EU over the past
year has had to take around a four
percent hit to their real wages
this worker can no longer afford to take
a well-learned holiday with their family
because electricity Heating and
rent is becoming more and more expensive
they just don't understand the world
anymore when you talk about social
justice
single mothers who
hear your speech about the child
guarantee as being cynical
it's completely cynical because in her
daily life as a single mother she's
trying to work out how to get food on
the table
but during your presidency food has
become 34 more expensive to feed her
children it didn't say anything about
the crisis and purchasing power
speculation you didn't stop that you
didn't
stop the force price Rises
you didn't introduce a sustainable
windfall profit tax
we're looking at recent figures that say
95 million people in the EU are
threatened by poverty that is your
achievement that you need to be judged
by
there was a pensioner in my constituency
in Eastern Germany you get 660 Euros a
month as his pension he's uh had a long
life of graft and it's too little to
live off but it's too much to die for
and this is a case of one in four
pensioners in the EU who cannot enjoy a
life of dignity there these pensioners
Twilight years are just as many light
years away from dignity as this European
commission is from the day-to-day life
of most people
so we've seen this house of Europe
that's been
turned into some sort of ramshackle ruin
your man on the moon for a long time has
been in free fall without a parachute
heading towards the hard ground of
reality
um what you what you do
well we see
you clutching onto the broken energy
Market the tax
break
without any economic Rhyme or Reason
we see
this
policy of just cutting payments cutting
money to your styming Investments for
the future about doing this
and you're stopping the fight against
poverty and that really borders on a
political denial of reality
and people are incandescent rightly so
you same time as your plague by
existential worries we see energy
companies and Food Corporation housing
companies making huge profits also the
armaments industry and just wonder uh
Madam president how you can sleep at
night 11
000 people have died on external borders
to EU since 2019 seven die every single
day and you talk about respect and
dignity and humanity and compassion well
looking at the deportation camps the
destruction of families militarization
of of the Border Police and lethal
pushbacks have nothing to do with
respect and dignity so stop with your
soap box oratory let's have policies
once and for all that's going to help
the majority of people
that seems to be a lack of respect by
this Commission of the people in Europe
normal people in Europe and their
situation and if you want a Europe that
is socially just ecological peaceful
then you have to
vote against the policies of this
commission thank you
next is titiana begin for one minute and
I am closing the list for requests for
catch the eye
Presidente
thank you president
Van Der lein in these four years you've
proven to be more of a marathon runner
than a sprinter and that in politics is
a merit but allow me to give you a piece
of advice and this last year in office
do not listen to the the
Sirens coming from European capitals but
concentrate solely on the common good
and the future of the European Union
hour and your goal should not be the
European Council in June 2024 but 2050
when we must reap the benefits of
today's policies to re-launch Europe do
not take the austerity of 2011-2012 as a
model but the next generation of 2020
the stability pact cannot be a copy
paste of past mistakes but must become
the springboard for a Greener more
technological
more social and fairer Europe
president the war in Ukraine is the
greatest threat to the Futures and lives
of European citizens let us bring it to
an end only diplomacy and dialogue can
bring peace back to the continent not
weapons thank you give the floor now
back to the president of the European
Commissioners for five minutes
thank you very much
thank you very much for the replies and
the discussion that we have started here
together as you know with the State of
the Union it is not only the speech to
be delivered but there's a letter of
intent that I've put forward
um and their limited number also on
additional initiatives let me address
some of them that have been mentioned
here my first point
is on the topic of rule of law
the rule of law is the glue of our Union
and we've done we've brought forward the
historic Next Generation EU package
because we knew it was of Paramount
importance
that we had to invest in the European
Union
this is common European Union
taxpayers money
and therefore there's a strong
obligation
that we connected with necessary reforms
in the respective member states
and if in member states there is there
are issues of the rule of law we've
connected this it to the investment of
Next Generation EU
and it is absolutely
not acceptable
that a member state
wants to access the funds of Next
Generation EU without having the reforms
that are we have agreed upon when
closing the contract for Next Generation
use so if you want to have taxpayers
money as investment in your member State
you have to abide to the rule of launch
you have to do the reforms that are
necessary
second point on our defense capabilities
first of all let me step one step
backwards looking at Ukraine
we all know we want peace in Ukraine but
it has to be a just peace and a lasting
one
and for that Ukraine needs security
guarantees
Kiev must be able and have the
capabilities to deter a new Russian
attack
and here Europe comes into play by
ensuring Ukraine's long-term security
which strong implications on our defense
industry
Europe's defense industry is running at
maximum speed we know this but it is not
enough because to empower Ukraine's
deterrence we must step up the
production of our capabilities military
capabilities and this is what we're
doing with ASAP for example the act in
support of ammunition production
and I would like to thank the European
Parliament and the council for passing
it in record time
we must also look Beyond this ammunition
topic Air Defense Maritime space and
cyber for example and these capabilities
are European by Nature no single member
State can alone develop them
so they require European Corporation not
only on research and development but
also on the industrial front
and this is why we will work on a
European Defense industry strategy
to look into how we can support our
industry ramp up the production of
critical equipment of course in Synergy
with NATO this is NATO this is
absolutely Paramount
no industrial bottleneck should prevent
us from protecting Europe and giving our
full support for Ukraine
and my third point I wanted to address
because it was
mentioned by many of you is the European
green deal
politics is also always also personal
during this mandate
since 2019
I
was blessed with my family that I had
three grandchildren
I was not a grandmother before that
and
since my mandate the experience of
welcoming three
little babies to this world
changes also the Deep conviction that
you have for the future of these
children because my perspective is a
very limited one but if I look at these
children or babies toddlers that they
are when they are two in 2030 they will
be in school age
in 2050 perhaps they want to have a
family and children
and now I of course over and over ask
myself and you do the same
will they have a spring a summer a fall
and a winter like we had it when we were
children
how will their future be will they be
able to have a known family how will the
world be and I know this is
definitely linked also on how we will
decide today about the European green
deal
so what I can only say here in front of
you honorable members is I am deeply
personally committed to the European
green deal because I know it is
Paramount for our survival but it is
also Paramount for our future Prosperity
if we make it and we can make it
together if we stand United thank you
very much thank you
I give the floor
now to the council to minister Jose
Alvarez Bueno for five minutes
Senora president
of the commission
on the line honorable members of the
European Parliament ladies and gentlemen
I'm appearing today on behalf of the
council in the house of European
democracy
the European Parliament all of you are
the reflection of Europe's diversity and
plurality
and are also the Union's most direct
contact with its citizens
I would like to start by thanking
president funderline
thank you for your speech and your
leadership throughout this legislature
it has been a challenging few years in
Europe with the pandemic
and now with Russia's aggression against
Ukraine but the union has been able to
rise to them president
thanks
to you thanks also to the commission and
thanks of course to this Parliament and
the members of the European Parliament
this is a decisive time for a European
unity and the conflict in Ukraine has
made the need for European values very
clear
on the first day of the Spanish
presidency the Spanish prime minister
Pedro Sanchez said a clear message to
the Ukrainian parliament in Keith we are
and will be standing with the people of
Ukraine for as long as it takes
a few weeks ago we strengthened our
joint commitment
to help and promote peace in Ukraine
at our meeting in Toledo
at the same time we're at a decisive
moment in the European calendar the
Spanish presidency is the last full
presidency before the European elections
in the next European legislative cycle
we will have to negotiate a large number
of dossiers which are key to European
integration
and which represents significant
progress in
social environmental and economic terms
because they have a positive impact on
the well-being of our fellow citizens it
is essential
that relations between the institutions
should continue to be as fluid as
possible
those relations between
commission Parliament and Commission in
Parliament a vital to the council and
the presidency being successful aware of
this the Spanish presidency has begun
with the utmost determination
demonstrating the Deep pro-european
vocation which drives the Spanish
government
the
first months of the presidency we had 17
try logs the pace will increase even
more in the coming months president you
can count on the full dedication of this
presidency to move the European project
forward
with ambition
Madam president I'm pleased to note that
the main elements
which you have highlighted here today
are in line with the priorities of the
Spanish presidency
the first is Green re-industrialization
and open strategic autonomy it's not
about building Fortress Europe
International openness has been and is
highly beneficial for the European Union
however this openness has on occasion
given rise to earn excessive dependence
in sectors which are key to the
well-being of our citizens we've seen
this in health
during the covid-19 pandemic
which brought so much suffering
in the form of unbearable human losses
we saw this in energy
following
Russia's unjustified
and
Lawless invasion of Ukraine in both
cases we faced these great challenges
with more Union because together we are
stronger that is why in the Spanish
presidency we are grateful for the
responses led by the European Commission
which are essential to face all these
challenges
we also
welcome the 2023 strategic foresight
Report with a vision of the future we
can continue to work together to build
more Europe we will dedicate one of the
major
events of the presidency to this
objective the Granada Summit
forthcoming on the 6th of October
to achieve this we must
diversify and strengthen ties with our
most reliable Partners in this regard I
would like to thank president funderline
and this Parliament for your
involvement with the Latin American and
Caribbean region the EU silac Summit was
a collective success which we hope will
be long lasting
and bring long-term benefits to all
Europeans the second priority is to make
progress on the green transition and
environmental adaptation curbing the
climate crisis and environmental
degradation is not only an unavoidable
necessity but also a great opportunity
to drastically reduce our energy
dependence and our electricity bill
making European companies more
competitive
and eliminating energy poverty among our
citizens
it is also an opportunity to create
quality jobs by boosting the circular
economy
the reform of the design of the
electricity Market the gas and hydrogen
package the regulations on the
conservation and restoration of
biodiversity Under The Net Zero industry
act are part of the Spanish presidency's
core dossiers
thirdly we need to promote greater
social and economic Justice we need a
more competitive economy without a doubt
but we also need
a fairer and more caring economy
and there's no contradiction between
these objectives they're perfectly
compatible among the major dossiers in
this block are the revision of the
multi-annual financial framework as well
as reforms of the rules of economic
governance both
of a structural nature for the European
Union
naturally the Spanish presidency of the
council will promote and support the
efforts of the commission and the
Parliament to achieve a more inclusive
Union
in that respect we'll make progress on
the initiatives and objectives set out
in the action plan of the European
pillar of social rights as well as on
the adoption of measures in favor of
equal treatment between people and their
inclusion paying special attention to
gender equality
and combating violence against women
as well as children's and disability
issues in that respect we welcome the
proposal for the disability card
directive which was presented by the
commission on the 5th of September
responding to the 87 million Europeans
with disabilities to ensure that Europe
is just one space for them too finally
the fourth priority is to strengthen
European Unity Unity is the element that
makes everything else possible
Unity is the engine that allows us to
move forward
in a context of heightened geopolitical
tensions the EU must remain United
and member states must continue
developing tools that will allow us to
face together the great challenges of
our time
it is crucial that we continue to
support Ukraine under the principles of
unity and solidarity
it is also essential to offer a real
perspective to our partners in the
western Balkans
in the vision of a wider European Union
we must advocate for an optimization of
decision-making processes we must be
able to agree to on a more efficient and
coordinated management of migration and
Asylum procedures
Humane orderly
caring and responsible management of
migration flows
we cannot let
hundreds of thousands of people
meet their end in the in the
Mediterranean with uh and we cannot
neglect our borders either Madam
president honorable members the Spanish
presidency is firmly convinced that the
future and well-being of all Europeans
can only come about through a more
united
stronger more social more sustainable
Union that is closer to its citizens
you can count on our full commitment to
continue making the union a project for
the future in which we're all included
women and men
in which all Europeans can see their own
faces reflected and no one is Left
Behind the Spanish presidency
in a nutshell wants to continue
applying European values for the benefit
of the people of Europe thank you very
much for your speech Madam president let
us continue working together to achieve
progress for Europe for one and a half
minutes
thank you with this state of the union
debate we're looking into the fifth year
of this commission but it also allows us
to look back at the previous four ones
and I have to say it feels like a life
that time but I mean that in a good way
because in 2019 we knew that we had to
embark on a double mission the green and
the digital transitions to ensure
sustainable growth and competitiveness
in Europe but we did not know that soon
after we would be fighting an unknown
virus we did not know what awaited us on
the 24th of February 2022 and we did not
know that we would be facing an
unprecedented energy price crisis
but we did react and react we we reacted
in a strong way in English you would say
we manned up but I think in this house
with good examples of female leadership
I should say and thank you by the way
for your words on gender equality but in
this context I should say we womened up
and in a way I think the commission
president has still been very modest yes
the state of the European Union is
strong but it was also agile Europe
reacted in a speed and in a flexibility
that was unprecedented that is unknown
in a number of member states my own
included and if I look forward to the
fifth year of this Commission
and in what also Philip Lombards might
be my last participation in a state of
the union debate let me put aside for
the party Party politics and simply say
this as elections come nearer many
politicians at home and some in this
house and thank you Mr lugout for
underlining that and then leaving the
room some even in this house will simply
blame the EU for everything that is
wrong in their eyes to them I say be
careful be careful what you wish for our
common European house is the best thing
that happened to us don't set it on fire
but man up women up and make sure it
stands the test of time thank you thank
you Ms alanga next is Elizabeth meaning
for one and a half minutes
yes thank you madam president I'm going
to speak in Italian
president will
many things have changed in Europe
during this parliamentary term and we're
very pleased that uh parts of our
socialist and Democrat agenda have
become parts of your agenda particularly
subsequent to the pandemic we supported
moving the European Union towards
solidarity rather than austerity
we
are still dealing with the market of
course but there are some things that
don't come back your party the Epp is
blocking some of the most important
measures of the green deal I mean that's
the truth of the situation at the end of
your speech you reassured us we want to
believe you but we're a bit skeptical
and then migration
you went to Tunisia together with
Georgia Maloney a Euro skeptic and
nationalist political party you were
looking to pay off a dictator so that
migrants would stay in Tunisia I don't
think that's an appropriate strategy I'm
in arm with a leader who wants to leave
the Europe who wants to leave the Euro
excuse me and says that the European
Union is like the Soviet Union it wants
to who wants to see a minimal European
Union in the service of member states
you can't become pro-european from one
day to the next
we need compulsory solidarity
and I think
you really need to tell us on which side
you're on are you on the side of Europe
as a pluralistic uh construct
or are you on the side of the
nationalists the right Wingers
at Europe that closes its doors because
either on one side or you're on the
other
we want to be true Europeans not
reluctant Europeans we want to see
Europe as a project that frees people
the Europe that David sassali wanted he
wanted to see Justice and freedom which
is what we all aspire to a Europe that
was good for women Europe that was based
on rights Europe of fraternity and hope
please tell us which side you're on give
the floor now to Malika's money for one
and a half minutes
well thank you madam president Dear Mr
President from The Lion there Ursula
first I would like to express my deepest
sympathy to the Moroccan and living
people who have been impacted by a
massive earthquake and a flood I expect
also that our Union to continue to help
them to overcome the strategy
uh their president one more year to go
and together we have achieved a lot in
the last four years that for some reason
feel like also much longer
my message to you today is and I know
you would agree do not rest on your
laurels there is more work and less time
if you ask me this term cannot be
successful without quick results from
the iotonesia deal
finishing the migration pact continues
and increased support to Ukraine we
cannot back down in our support for the
brave Ukrainian people
and finally our economy we need to boost
our competitiveness focus on our
industry in small and medium-sized
Enterprises and provide access to cruel
to critical raw materials and enhance
our defense capability capabilities
people throughout Europe continue to
struggle with inflation Energy prices
are not predictably stable and the cost
of living continue to rest
this means that where we spend our money
on and how is under immense scrutiny we
know the populist will explore this
we cannot allow them to do so
dear President we only have a few months
before the elections to show that this
term was your best term so far
so let's do just that thank you very
much for one minute
thank you madam commission president
during year and hour mandate some
circumstances mostly unexpected push us
to have to kind of reinvent ourselves as
a union we took decisions that were
Unthinkable a few years ago and we
became more aware of ourselves as a
political Community with values and
interest to stand for and I must admit
Madame Wonderland that this has happened
under your impulse with cross-party
alliances in this Parliament and despite
the fact that in you we still have
rather sporadic ways of functioning
this political ambition cannot Decay now
we cannot bow down to those who call
with misleading Arguments for an end to
much needed policies like those of the
green deal we need to go on facing our
challenges with political ambition
without leaving anyone behind with more
attention to social issues which has
been the big missing thing in your
speech and guided by a sense of
responsibility towards future
generations and you mentioned Europe's
diversity I hope next time in next
debates I can address you in my mother
tongue which is Catalan thank you
foreign
Manifesto some of which we share some
which we don't some of it's coming very
late
here are our priorities for the coming
months we need to reform economic
governments putting growth and
Investments at the heart of what we do
and stopping these continual
senseless increases in interest rates
being put out by the European Central
Bank which are causing inflation and
problems
we need to support Agriculture and
Manufacturing
we need to reduce the regulatory
proliferation which is damaging our
businesses we need to bring back our
strategic businesses to Europe and
finally the commitments taken on
yesterday by the German and French
governments well you didn't say anything
about that and that means that we need a
clear solution to human trafficking now
more than ever we need to deal with
illegal immigration which is making our
cities unsafe from words to Deeds please
for two minutes
thank you very much president of
parliament Madam president from the Lion
the time for stock taking has come
but there's a big gap between the words
of your speeches and the reality
experienced by millions of Europeans
you can see as president of a respected
institution you are in a cold and
weakened institution that people don't
believe in anymore
institution that makes speeches but
we're seeing at the same time a
reduction of influence of Europe around
the world never before seen because of
the influence of the left you're now
suggesting we should get rid of the
combustion engine and weakening our
industry
and then you have the farm to Fork that
is weakening our agriculture as well the
energy Market in Europe is being
undermined because you're not
supporting nuclear which means that my
people in France are having to put huge
bills that affects the most modest those
were the most modest incomes we can see
that there's all sorts of disorder of
the future that you're organizing today
with people coming from the south
changing our culture and completely
changing our way of life
in your own Majesty the European
institutions have profit all sorts of
ideas about
campaigns of advertising
which are undermining the way of life
we see a lack of certainty covid war on
our Shores once again artificial
intelligence the demographic challenge
even a challenge to have very
civilization that's at risk of Despair
despairing we have to continue European
construction has to exist
and we have to find a way of the
strength of people that's the only the
only way we can do this is have
independent Sovereign peoples who can
meet the challenges to rival China or
the United States I would encourage
people to look at the 6th to the ninth
of June marketing your Diaries they can
do something to change the future long
live the 9th of June go for one minute
gracias president
thank you president
we have said this to you in the past
there's a funderline
you are very ingenious at marketing and
propaganda
you have treated us to
half truths and zero self-criticism it
all sounds wonderful though
but there wasn't any time left to talk
about the true causes of inflation
the more than 2 000 deaths caused by the
eu's migration policy so far this year
or the rise in mortgages caused by the
European Central Bank is so far from The
Ordinary People of Europe
your speech was so far from them
human rights workers rights
didn't hear it once
economic policy that doesn't
squeeze the last drops out of families
in order to enrich Banks and
multinationals true change that will
resolve the energy crisis there's a
proposal missing there for ordinary
people thank you for one minute
thank you dear colleagues
reunion quite differently
brexit illegal migration covets the war
in Ukraine and the ensuing economic
crisis would all have required capable
leadership and the right decisions
instead we see ad hoc reactions
grandiose self-congratulating statements
and consequently the loss of credibility
the pointless centralization efforts in
all policy areas in Brussels or the
shameful ideological Jihad against
conservative governments all create
Division and weaken Europe
also a huge corruption scandal in this
Parliament and the scandalous vaccine
procurement by the commission must be
tackled head on we've been waiting for
your text messages when I'm president
for over 863 days now still counting
not to mention
not to mention the intolerably slow
disbursement of rrf money to member
states or the failed sanctions policy
sorry to say that hasn't really helped
Ukraine in any meaningful way it hasn't
brought the end of the war any closer
but it's hurting the European economy
and European people Europe must find its
way back to Unity and credibility by
accepting itself first as an alliance of
free member states and then defining its
own strategic interests in the world
thank you next Siegfried murazan for one
minute
uh thank you president fonderlein thank
you very much for putting
competitiveness back at the heart of
Europe's agenda this will make our
economy stronger and it will allow us to
safeguard high social standards in
Europe thank you very much for putting
Farmers back on the European agenda
Farmers had to manage High uncertainty
since the Russian invasion they need all
our support and we have to make sure
that grain from Ukraine gets to where it
is needed in Northern Africa and the
Middle East and doesn't flood the
markets in central eastern Europe and
doesn't become a risk for farmers and EU
member states thank you for also
supporting the accession of Bulgaria and
Romania to the Schengen area Romania and
Bulgaria joining the Schengen area will
make the whole changan area stronger
will make Europe as a whole safer two
points for my side firstly whenever
people are in need of support in Europe
support is coming we have shown this in
a pandemic and in times of War one of
our main tools to provide support is the
budget you have put forward the proposal
for the revision of the multi-annual
financial framework because it is
getting to its limits it has to to do
more than it was anticipated let's work
together to get this done before the end
of the year to provide stable finances
for the next years to be able to do more
for defense for military Mobility for
people who are coming to Europe and who
need support for tackling illegal
migration because whatever is illegal
has to be tackled of course my second
and last point we can only live in
safety and stability within the borders
of the European Union if we are
surrounded by countries which are safe
and stable this is why let's start
accession negotiations with Ukraine and
Moldova that does not mean that the
countries will join now it just means
that we make them stronger and fitter
for recession which is good for those
countries and good for the European
Union there is a wide majority in
Parliament for this thank you very much
thank you next is Pedro Marcus for one
and a half minutes
[Applause]
thank you madam president today I'll be
speaking in my mother tongue in
Portuguese
Senora president admission
presidents presidents of the commission
the commissioners
Madam president you see the glasses half
full other CA others see it as half
empty it is with pride that we in the
half full part find conditions that
socialists put in place to support your
election a Porto's social agenda
European minimum wages green deal to
tackle the climate emergency effective
criminalization of those who don't
respect the rule of law
uh it's uh Alban is so fond of Euro
bonds that made it possible to create
the covert crisis recovery plan these
were measures of enormous importance but
Madam president there is still half a
glass to fill and you have to decide how
you want to end your mandate how are you
going to put European policies at the
service of those suffering from
inflation and Rising living and housing
costs your one hour long silence on
those who are suffering the most in
Europe today was deafening and as for
those suffering on our borders you
talked about The Pact for migration but
at the same time you did deals with
dictators to export our challenges
and it didn't say a word about saving
lives in the Mediterranean or did you
say anything about how you intend to
push for New Economic rules that will
help us to avoid recession in Europe and
with a strong priority for social
cohesion but I want to make it clear to
you too we enjoyed listening to you and
I'm sure Mr Weber did too giving
absolute priority to the green deal and
restoring nature so it's up to you madam
president to decide how you want to end
your term we need you to put the energy
into responding to the living crisis
Europeans are paying attention and the
weakest need action don't fail to meet
the expectations of hundreds and
millions of citizens
their colleagues
looking back to our mandate so far there
is a lot to be proud of
we're still United in the face of
unprecedented challenges during the
pandemic or during Putin's brutal
invasion of Ukraine but this mandate is
far from Over the global political
climate is extremely turbulent and
liberal democracy is under increasing
threat
and we have to ask ourselves the
question is the EU prepared for the
prospects of a second Trump presidency
because we have to be and strategic
autonomy is the place to start and we
have to put treaty change on the table
and we have to abolish the unanimity
rule at least in foreign affairs
Madam president you told us if and when
if necessary well I have to tell you the
time is now for that because for Europe
to be a ball work of democracy we have
for us to be a strong Ally of Ukraine we
have to put our own house in order we
cannot fight Putin without fighting the
putinization of our very own member
states and in the past years after some
hesitation I have to say the commission
indeed took firm steps to address
Democratic backsliding and clearly there
is growing pressure to abandon this path
but we cannot and we must not do this
our values and an unwavering commitment
to rule of law action is simply
non-negotiable colleagues the bird needs
Europe's voice and Leadership like never
before but Europe is only as strong as
our values are thank you very much
[Applause]
colleagues the far right is saying that
a choice will have to be made on the 9th
of June a choice with regard to our
civilization and that's true either we
will choose decline inward-looking
National nationalist policy or we will
choose green policies to respond to the
challenges facing on facing Us in the
sphere of the climate and social policy
Madam president I listened closely to
your speech which in some regards was
bold but I want to talk here about
ecology about green policies because I
heard your words but also your silence
you speak of the beauty of European
forests but you're silent when it comes
to restoring nature and the law on
nature restoration must be adopted we
need to Hue here to our principles you
seem to be trapped trapped in the uh
backward looking dogma of your political
family but you know that the climate
crisis leaves us no choice and you must
understand that Economic Policy must not
come above climate policy
we need to work with our planetary
limits our ecosystems have rights too
and those rights need to be upheld we
need to move away from our toxic
environmental policy
we must ban the exports of chemical
substances and pesticides which we
consider to be too dangerous to be
authorized for use on the European
continent and we need a law on Animal
Welfare the fight for Ecology is a fight
to safeguard the possibility of living
on our planet
that's our common Duty and we need to
stand firm in the face of climate
Skeptics thank you going out is highly
famous for one minute
[Applause]
thank you president Madam Thunder lion
you mentioned a geopolitical commission
but
in the meantime we've seen
that there's been a super bond in Italy
of 110 and that has to be paid by us in
Sweden
and we're well aware of the fact that
things are going very badly
now clearly
I'm talking about a whole series of
measures you want to impose upon
European citizens for example
we know that there's a series of funds
that are going to have to be used
to get Class A certification in the
energy sector and that goes too for the
funds that Swedish citizens will be
using but are you happy after having
voted
a whole series of legal acts for example
on nature but all of this runs counter
to the interests of families there's a
whole series of restructuring measures
that are going to be imposed by force
now
and that's completely unacceptable
because we don't know whether citizens
can continue like this thank you
in March 2000 the commission announced
the Lisbon strategy the aim was the by
2010 the EU would become the most
dynamic competitive
economic zone in the world in
2010 well it came and went the strategy
had failed push back yet again 2020 you
president
acknowledge that you would focus more on
well-being than Prosperity that goal has
been achieved for Germany 6.2 percent
inflation well over at the oecd average
negligible rise in productivity German
export Surplus has halved foreign direct
investment has fallen by 80 compared to
and minus 0.3 percent that's the worst
worst economic in the IMF
at an unprecedented rate German
companies are relocating production
abroad to flee High Energy prices you I
can acknowledge it president you are
achieving your goals but our well-being
was better served by the failures of
your predecessors than your successors
is Nikolai willemsen for one minute
dear terminal the commission
I'm sorry but reality calls
this should be a matter of the condition
of the European Union not a conservative
uh fight for elections should be about
normal people in Europe under pressure
from rising prices while energies
speculators uh win a lot of money it
should be about the globe that is
burning under our feet the acute climate
crisis but we see that the short-term
profit interests are at the top of the
agenda
we see that climate action Environmental
Protection are de-watered Animal Welfare
legislation may be given up
we see that the reform of the rich
chemicals legislation at the ban against
pfas may not be coming after all it just
cannot be right
dear chair of the commission you are
running away from your election promises
do not fail us Europe needs climate
action animal welfare and Social
Security
no
more broken election promises thank you
I mean for one minute
thank you president
uh
Madam president
the future of the Union is linked
inextricably to the future of the member
of State in 1978 the Spanish state went
through a crucial political set of
negotiations transitioning from
dictatorship to democracy and this
enabled a few years on for Spain to join
the European Union
now this transition led to the 1978
regime and this was a turning point not
just for Spain but for the whole of
Europe for the Europe's stability and
Future
today
the Spanish state is moving towards what
could be the most important decisive
political negotiations since the
transition and as was the time then
Europe's stability depends on that too
only if the Spanish state is able to
find a solution to its conflict with
Catalonia rooted in human rights
democracy and the respect
relating to civil and political rates
the right to self-determination
will that solution be solid and
sustainable that is why we feel that the
European commission ought to keep a
close eye on these negotiations which
are so key not just to Catalonia but to
the union and the Spanish state itself
and there to be a responsible attitude
towards these negotiations on the part
of the commission thank you
thank you president dear president
Ponder Lyon on this occasion of the last
debate of the State of the Union of this
mandate let me thank you for your
outstanding leadership namely in the
pandemic in the support to Ukraine
you have been living you are living
worldwide our fight in Ukraine for
democracy and values of Human Rights and
that is a measure achievement for
geopolitical European Union
thank you very much Ursula Vander lion I
come from a country
where inflation
linked to high interest rates and
Antonio Costa's policy of Maximum taxes
with minimum Services where 90 of
households
have mortgages that are on variable
rates and in that country families and
companies are suffering greatly and for
that reason it's very important it's a
vital importance that the European Union
has a strategy to combat inflation that
can actually highlight the fact that the
ECB should think again about Rising
interest rates we have to do as the US
does we have to have a strategy to
combat inflation and it's vital to say
to my colleague here Pedro March many of
the problems he raised are the result of
the eight years where Antonio Costa's
policies forgot families and companies
and concentrated on maximum tax minimum
services
dear president from The Lion first I
welcome your recognition that Romania
and Bulgaria are part of Schengen let's
say that today is the day for a
commitment Romania in Bulgaria in
Schengen by the end of this mandate
thank you uh second you mentioned the
important role of the European regions
therefore it is crucial to have a strong
cohesion policy a strong policy cohesion
funding to ensure the convergence of all
the regions within the European Union
third to continue the address the
addressing the challenges of today and
tomorrow a timely agreement on all the
components of the mff revisions is
absolutely necessary the parliament is
working hard and is committed to having
a revised mff in place on January 1st
2024 and we call on the presidential
Michelle to put the dmff on the European
council's October agenda we count on
your support and Leadership thank you so
much thank you very much Miss Plum next
is Nicola Dante for one minute
foreign
thank you president
we have faced in these years challenges
that seemed Unthinkable even four years
ago and we've managed to deliver
responses to kovid like the recovery
plan managed to respond also to the
Ukraine crisis but of course there are
still huge challenge that await us and
let me mention three here firstly Europe
may be pushed aside on a world stage
there's a problem of our demographic
issues there's a problem with managing
our migration flows we may still be a
great trade power but we are facing
globalization with no rules on a global
scale so there have been measures set
out again there should be measures set
out against Chinese dumping then we want
to see
Europe uh step up we need to be able to
face up to the challenges ahead of us
and I would have liked to hear more on
treaty reform in this regard from you
now strategic responses and when it
comes to protecting our critical
Material supplies and energy we have
some dear industrialization but we need
to do more on this as well
we need to find responses and the
response lies in uh in US Europe to
ensure that we have a model with more
solidarity where we show more leadership
on the Glo on the global stage only if
we're able to live up to what we did in
covid we'll be able to face down these
challenges and for one minute
thank you
commission president
I am concerned about Europe's future
because far right eurosceptings Skeptics
are gaining ground in many countries
around Europe and here in this house
it looks like they will start to form
majorities and coalitions it is
important that you as commission
president do not turn a blind eye to
this problem that you stand up to it it
is true that many people fear for their
future High Energy prices affording
accommodation seeing eroding income high
prices
that's a Working Poor that is what we
have for many people in Europe we need a
social policy for all the EU needs to
offer citizens Social Security we need
the EU a minimum income directive to be
biding so that uh action can be taken in
Germany we need to look at companies
offering Fair jobs at decent work and
that should be conditioned for access to
EU funding we need to look at crumbling
infrastructure not allow it to
deteriorate further we would like to see
more courageous action in your part and
take a stand against and perhaps take
action along the lines of the
anti-inflation act in the U.S
optimistic
I am optimistic
last year I was filled with pessimism
skyrocketing Energy
prices as a result of a transition that
had not been properly planned decimated
Supply chains as a result of pointless
lockdowns woke movements destroying
European values hyperinflation due to
ECB monetary policy but we have steadied
the ship people have raised their voices
this cannot go on we have changed course
realism has gained ground it has
taken root here too not just voters have
changed their minds the epp2 has turned
away from the left at the German economy
is suffering and so the rest of Europe
is we are at the eve of European
elections we see what's happening in
society huge change it is my fervent
hope that uh
9th of June 2024 will Herald a new era
an era in which realistic forces in this
Parliament will build a new majority a
nearer in which the EU does what it is
supposed to improve people's lives we're
working on renewal of democracy so
president I am optimistic one minute
colleges president colleagues we knew
that after brexit the commission
could not push further with
the European
project but we saw actual extremism EU
fanaters Fanatics support
and the commission president has
underscored that this will continue
along similar lines
European extremism we've seen that in
healthcare migration a continuation of
the migration pact more migration we see
the enlargement of gender driven by the
commission
we see green left majorities in the
green agenda being pushed forward it's a
disaster for farming industry and
citizens indeed look at accommodation
prices
people are really suffering
the commission
has implemented a great reset to
expansive a program
the commission needs to go we need fewer
Fanatics and few extreme pro-europeans
and I hope that was your last state of
unionist beach
go ahead
as an achievement you presented the
increase of the war effort in Ukraine
with thousands of dead in the new
imperialistic conflict between the
European Union United States NATO
against Russia and we have increasing
competition with China for controlling
the markets and the raw resources they
don't
so with these are billions taken from
people who are working and we cannot use
this money to protect people from
wildfires from floods and we have
touched this because the European Union
consists considers the cost of
protection very high
we are financing the green big companies
and we have also the directive for
transparency in working times and we
have tough uh very tough conditions 13
hours of of work not paid over time and
this is the European Union it's not
being corrected the people can leave
behind uh being refugees the war
uncertainty if they take in their hands
the control and the government and they
go away from receiving these alliances
as the European Union and NATO and have
a Europe that protects their own
interests
thank you president for your strong
leadership
we must achieve the EU enlargement no
later than 2030.
for this it is necessary to invite
Ukraine and Moldova for negotiations
already this year
there has never been in history such a
case a nation fighting horrific military
war carry us out reforms and strengthens
democracy all at the same time the
ukrainians are doing it with a strong
determination does the EU have the same
we also need to prepare to reform
without delay but some EU countries are
dragging their feet
some forget solidarity to slogans and
complain even overgrain some are afraid
of Ukraine's crushing military victory
over Russia what will happen to Russia
they ask
I can answer with certainte Ukraine's
Victory will open their way for
Democratic change in Russia and in
Belarus it will free all Russia's
Neighbors from the Gremlins blackmail
and threats Ukraine's Victory will bring
lasting peace in Europe
therefore I say not as long as it takes
but until Ukraine's Victory thank you
until our Victory thank you thank you
Raza next is Alex
foreign
with bravery that we can give full
protection to our citizens in a digital
world we have been brave when we put
forward like you rightly said our act on
Digital Services and on the Digital
Services Act we also were Brave when we
approved the common charger there were
those who laughed at us at the time but
yesterday we saw the the biggest company
worldwide that after 13 years of
resistance it implemented a standard
that we agreed upon about a year ago
with the same ambition and determination
we would we need to do more
we need to have a better enforcement so
that it doesn't remain a nice law on
paper the DSA and the dma we must
immediately conclude
on the ACT on in intelligence and they
act on data the European commission must
move and Implement as soon as possible
The Proposal approved by the European
Parliament on the right to disconnect
we must invest on digital knowledge
because so that those who are most
vulnerable are not excluded or
discriminated against we must protect
our consumers when they shop online we
must also protect the
our citizens previously online from
surveillance thank you very much minute
[Applause]
College Madam president dear colleagues
I have attentively listened to the State
of the Union presentation and its
achievements and I agree with many of
the priorities but let's not pretend we
do not see the elephant in the room the
blocking of Schengen area for Romania
and Bulgaria in Bridge of the treaties
and this is not a secondary topic as a
Romanian I cannot see how we can advise
these priorities together as long as the
council has a duty towards 27 million
citizens of the European Union Romanians
and bulgarians
who are denied a right established by
the treaty the abusive and defiant
behavior of the Austrian government
cannot continue this is enough enough is
enough
Madam president
representative of the council the
commission has done its part and I would
like to thank you for that the
parliament has done its job on this
topic and I would like to thank my
colleagues for that now it is the
council's turn to solve this problem
which is undermining The credibility of
the Union as long as we are not able to
solve apparently simple simple problem
but with a strong and important impact
on some citizens of European Union in
that case Romanians and bulgarians thank
you next is Rob
vice president one minute
[Applause]
Madam president Madam president of the
commission there were many ambitious
points in your speech which of course
belong in such speeches but we know that
people rather believe in deeds and there
are Deeds that have been well done for
instance overcoming the energy crisis
last year providing political and
financial support to Ukraine there are
also good commitments for instance to
strengthen the fight against human
trafficking crimes to admit Ukraine to
the EU without calling a convention and
undergoing a long process of amending
the EU treaties but in your speech Madam
president you didn't mention a word
about the military capacity of the EU
which is strongly lagging behind our
transatlantic partners and ukrainians
definitely see that also the Eastern
European citizens who are living next to
the aggressor the citizens see that
Global changes are underway and from a
geopolitical point of view the most
important thing is to develop maximum
cooperation with our Global Western
partners and that would be in my opinion
a more important message about security
at the end of the speech than the
invitation to think great which is a
fair paraphrase of Let's Make Europe
great again
I think the accents could have been
better but thank you
after the president
thank you
Miss from The Lion I'll speak Estonian
in your opening speech today you gave
the example of wanting children to grow
up in a clean environment and you
highlighted the importance of the green
deal it is true children need a healthy
environment but when it comes to the
green deal they are not foolish you are
not foolish look at the figures
four percent of CO2
added to the environment comes from
human activity
and the percentage the European
proportion is seven percent there and
when it comes to children
what is most important is something you
mentioned in your speech migration and
Technology yet I didn't hear anything
about democracy in your speech
I heard someone say we need migrants we
need immigrants no we need our own
children I would like to send a message
to the commission how can we increase
the birth rate so that we have children
to look after Europe
president in your speech you told that
it is the moment for the Youth to answer
the call of History
the whole one of the goals of history
now is unprecedenting Rises taking place
its crisis of falling Capital efficiency
the element of which is a structural
recession of the economic economy the
world is breaking up in the currency
zones and we have to pose the question
what is the place of the EU in the new
world map we'll see you managed to
create a non-economic Zone and this is a
strategic the existential question to
pose now four times I was elected to the
European Parliament the program of my
party contained the slogan of Charles de
Gaulle Europe from Lisbon to rural to
our regret it was in 2000 being in 2004
a real opportunity now it has lost
opportunity and the characteristic of
modern history is regrettably the time
of thank you very much opportunities
next is Daniel kaspari one minute
in the last four years very difficult
years we've achieved a lot together we
survived the covert pandemic as well as
any other region we've responded to
Russian war in Ukraine we've stood
United we've managed to launch the
European green deal and done our part to
tackle human caused climate change thank
you for your tireless efforts in these
difficult years
however despite our successes you've
already mentioned that there are some
areas where we need to improve or
restart matters we need to ensure
competitiveness we need companies in
Europe that have a real Prospect for the
future we need to reach out to the
farming communities and prevent
polarization we need to tackle inflation
and preserve social Unity on our common
security and defense policy we need to
do better so that we can better protect
European borders you've discussed all
these issues today let's uh work
together to build Europe's next success
story
commission president
we have set ourselves the target
of having 15 million fewer people living
in poverty by 2030 in Europe whereas if
we continue on the current course we'll
have 50 million more people living in
poverty now we're talking about people
and very often people feel that they are
weighed down they see Rising prices
rising food prices Energy prices at the
same time homelessness is rising
and so on and so forth it is so
important that Europe looks to see where
it can help to find a solution so that
we can ease the pressure on people we
need to look at EU funds see if we can
better support social housing look at
the different rules and see where we can
find Solutions that's very important
when it comes to trust you talk about uh
hospitals
that go to those people that are
striking they are being exploited what
is Europe doing to ensure that mobile
workers are not being left doing the
dirtiest work worth conditions we do
want mobile workers but we're on decent
conditions thank you
president I hope that you're going to be
flexible for me for one
thank you always flexible with your time
because it's my last intervention on the
State of the Union after 15 years in
Parliament and 10 years in the council
so thank you
[Applause]
um I have to tell you uh Mr President
that I missed something and I'm really
in this agreement with you on one thing
so I missed something that was the
European Defense Union and that's more
than the common production of ammunition
for a great can you imagine that we are
in the same situation in a war with
Ukraine with Trump coming back as a
president
and without having the backing of NATO
so European Defense units absolutely
clear and necessary for the future uh
and the second thing what I'm in
complete disagreement with you and
you're the first president of the
commission will try to do that that is
your suggestion to decouple
uh the enlargement of the European Union
but the deepening of the European Union
yeah you said let's try with the with 35
with 36 I can tell you
see you a European Union before your
eyes were 35 36 Commissioners or
something like that we have already no
task for them today we're 27.
or secondly can you imagine the European
Union with uh yeah still the unanimity
rule you said yeah but we managed it you
managed it
let's give the examples migration
migration we managed it is breakthrough
because we get the unanimity because for
seven years the council said we're gonna
do it but unanimity it's better than
with qualified majority even when in the
treaty it's foresee by qualified
majority so the Breakthrough came
because we skipped unanimity and the
same in sanctions Mr zielinski the
president of Ukraine is right he's
saying that the counter-offensive of
Ukraine goes with the speed light
compared to the sanctioned policy of the
European Union you're not capable
anymore to decide on additional
sanctions against Russia because of
unanimity in European Union because one
or two countries are opposing it
so I think we need to absolutely this
reform of the treaties and in my opinion
I I ask in any way the Spanish
presidency by the end of the year when
they open the negotiations with the
candidate member State not to do it if
at the same time we don't open or so the
debate on the reform of the treaties
thank you very much next is Harold
vilimski for one minute
thank you
thank you for president thank you
president ladies and gentlemen
in
German we tend to say you shouldn't pat
yourself on your back and that is what
is happening here this morning your
ignoring the disastrous State of Affairs
in the European Union give me this
opportunity
to pick up on a few areas
where the EU has failed peace
Freedom Prosperity peace
well we've had 11 sanctioned packages
and we still stay conflict weapons being
delivered
huge amounts of funds being pumped into
keeping the war going but no one is
talking about peace no one is doing
anything to start peace negotiations
that is a key failure what about Freedom
well look at what is happening in Europe
the digital Service Act
the fact that cash is being
um
eroded and where people are struggling
fearing for their future struggling to
make ends meet
it cannot continue in this way and what
about Prosperity well inflation is in
double digits we saw the ridiculous
lockdown policy during covert
ridiculous payments to hurricane
the Europeans are picking up the tab U.S
Russia they're all uh turning over a
profit but we've completely failed and
no one is acknowledging that so we
should not be rubbing our hands and Glee
patting ourselves in the back we should
acknowledge failures
foreign
I will read out a part of your
report
from last year on the State of the Union
the Russian industry is in Ruins Isle of
flood is grounding its planes because
they do not have spare parts
Russian army takes chips from
dishwashers and washing machines to
repair their technology but what is the
reality
your German tanks are burning on the
Russian front lines
ten thousands of Slavic people are dying
and the Russian economy is not in a
catastrophic State we all know what is
the true reason behind this war it's Mrs
Funderland knows it Mrs Metzel I know
that our commissioner chefchovich knows
this the vice president of the European
Parliament Mr shimichkar knows it even
though he doesn't know anything he he
wouldn't even greet an older colleague
from Slovakia if my father would not uh
greet if my son would not greet him I
would really slap him in the face very
hard
um so what is behind it the the uh
effort of the United States to occupy
Europe to occupy the world to occupy
ports in the Black Sea and the cream
Crimean Peninsula let's start discussing
uh peace and we will get rid of the
problems in Europe thank you very much
so Andre halitsky for one minute
foreign
Europe
strong courageous
large
making progress in the direction that
citizens want to see it moving and that
of well-being and prosperity
I was happy to see that in the speech
today from Adam Van Der Lyon Farmers
took up a great part of that speech the
efforts that they make and how important
they are for food security for Polish
Farmers work very hard but they do need
help because some of them are very close
to going bankrupt
what's happening in Ukraine shouldn't
prevent us from providing assistance to
our farmers in Poland
we
hope that next year
depending on what happens in the
situation there'll be a rational
decision from the European commission
along these lines and we have to avoid
any of the blackmail attempts by Russia
polish Farmers need help from the
European Union and they deserve it thank
you
thank you
Madam president
the challenge of Russian aggression and
geopolitical shift in the world heavily
influences our International Trade
policy
distorted value change and problems with
access to critical raw materials weaken
our EU strategic autonomy
we need to defend our Global interests
as the main exporting superpower
increase our strategic Independence and
support our industry with the inflow of
needed raw materials
for this reason I urge you to finalize
the important trade deals with Latin
American countries
implement the New Zealand FDA and
Advance negotiations with Australia and
India
our trade deals need to be supported by
revised TSD chapters with a sanctions
mechanism whenever possible
this should go along with the
implementation of the due diligence
directive to cover International value
chains and a working ban on Imports of
products coming from Forced labor thank
you
thank you very much next is Vice
President insurance
thank you very much Madam president
Madam president since the start of this
mandate we have been fighting crisis
first covet and now the war
these have had Direct negative impact on
our citizens and European
competitiveness
from Energy prices to inflation Europe
is struggling to maintain our place in
regards to the U.S China and the rest of
the world
Without A Renewed focus on
competitiveness we will end up in the
world where we are merely consumers of
products and services from elsewhere
president our answer to this problem
cannot be so solely with unlimited State
AIDS or subsidizing our Industries
instead Europe needs to invest invest in
new Industries new sectors and new
technologies
focus on fewer and better regulations
because over-regulation holds Innovation
back let China keep the factories of the
20th century Europe should create a new
business environment of 21st century
thank you thank you very much next is
Jurg moyten one minute
president president commission president
honorable members Europe
is in the throes of a crisis millions of
Europeans barely know how they can
afford daily necessities
they see what is happening with
industrialization and unfettered mass
migration into Europe it we urgently
need change these are existential
problems yet the EU your commission is
indulging in irresponsible hubris absurd
targets
linked to climate change you have got it
wrong you uh will not halt anything
you
will fail in your efforts on climate
change and you need to take the right
measures
we need to adapt our society to climate
change
you have focused on a single task and
you are tackling it in the wrong way and
the EU May
falter as a whole and that is what would
be historic
your excellencies you have lied to us
you have repeatedly lied to us you are
humiliating and fooling us constantly
although we are modal European citizens
we are responsible and open tolerant and
hardworking we have made huge efforts
and we have widely opened our doors for
6 million ukrainians that were fleeing
from Putin's aggression we are putting
our farmers in great difficulty because
they have to keep thousands of tons of
grains in their barns or on the field in
order to receive Ukrainian creams that
had to reach Northern Africa and Europe
but which remain in huge quantities on
Armenian territory we have secured our
borders and this morning the Romanians
on the southern border with Ukraine have
received a large messages because of the
pieces of drones falling from the other
uh Shore you are not capable to put
pressure and to stop Chancellor lehemer
of Austria from humiliating and defying
a country with 25 million European
citizens the hammer is they find and
humiliating not only Romania but he is
mocking the Euro system and all of you
and the council and especially you dear
jerusala you Roberta are making promises
after promises and we are watching how
Romania an example of ethnic and
religious tolerance of fair partnership
for NATO military forces is haunted by
the ghost of extremism anti-europeism
and intolerance marginal parties have
become dangerous because of Austria's
refusal to accept Us in Schengen and
because of your incapacity to convince
the Austrian Chancellor that he's making
a serious mistake towards common Europe
I hear words like solidarity Union and
other jokes what solidarity when
Romanians are being humiliated in the
airport we are talking about unity and
equal opportunities when Romanians
standing huge cues at the borders you
have fed us Illusions while Austria is
running after contract and Romania is
waiting for one thing due respect that's
all respect and equal opportunities for
a common Europe
one minute
thank you
you said it well president four years
ago no one could imagine that we would
live in this kind of world in this kind
of Union
we live in a union where 37 million
people cannot afford a decent daily meal
in the union where in some member states
two-thirds of people cannot make ends
meet
in a union where every fifth person
lives on the brink of poverty on the
other hand we live in a union where
companies worth millions pay very low
taxes
and the citizens in my country Croatia
and in other countries feel that for
every crisis the bill is passed on to
them either through higher prices or
lower quality
your promises about a social Union based
on which we gave you our trust four
years ago is more is now more important
than ever we cannot leave our citizens
to the mercy of the market the EU must
work for its citizens thank you then
beer one minute thank you William
in geopolitical times we are facing
difficulties Parliament Council and
commission stood United in the face of
Russia's war of aggression in Ukraine
I would like to seen more such Unity
um in other areas and recognition of
parliament's role as strong Parliament
is vital for a strong EU within and
Beyond its borders to ensure prosperity
and competitiveness in Europe
we need to protect the middle classes
smes they are the backbone to ensure a
suffering open Europe we cannot allow
too much red tape to weigh on our econ
economies four years ago Mrs funderline
you talked about freeing smes from
excessive red deep one in one out but we
don't really see the red tape being cut
we have the SME package but it's come
far too late we need to give fresh
impetus to our economy and a future to
our citizens one minute
specific thank you madam president thank
you President Van delay and I agree with
you in the challenges facing us and you
have our support but today I have to
talk about the seriousness of what's
happening in Spain which is currently
chair and Council it's unusual unheard
of for the Prime Minister not to appear
in this chamber to defend the priorities
of the Spanish presidency and he's not
doing that because of where his
interests lie he doesn't want to debate
in public what he's deciding and
negotiating on in private
Piedmont is asking for an amnesty as an
exchange for him becoming prime minister
again now an amnesty means negating the
existence of crimes and it means doing
away with the separation of powers it
would jeopardize rule of law the
European people's party is not going to
stay silent while the Prime Minister
thinks about seeding to this attack on
rule of law
the possible avoidance of his
electoral defeat can't lead to the
humiliation of Spain thank you son one
minute
thank you president commission president
well we have seen
climate change flooding heat waves all
across the EU
we've seen the rise in food prices as
well as Energy prices as well
violence is on the rise against women
in fact there's been a rollback when it
comes to gender parity in the EU
so now we need to think about the kind
of world that we're going to be living
to our children and grandchildren
and so I support what president
Wonderland has said we need to move
forward push forward on the green deal
despite the conservatives in this house
despite everything that's been done in
Sweden we need to carry on pushing
against climate change
we need to think of our climate
objectives from here until 2040.
and what's more we're going to need to
fight against violence against women
thank you very much for what you said
it's important no means no thank you
thank you madam president president
you said today in this chamber the rule
of law is the pillar and Foundation of
our Union but we know that there are
countries that gradually have downgraded
their democracies and we've only acted
when it's too late now we have major
challenges facing US economic challenges
social environmental challenges but
believe me Madam president there is no
State of the Union if there isn't rule
of law
and we have seen countries that have
blocked the way in which judges are
appointed because he can't control them
and it is thinking about
not taking people to court in order to
get votes they are undermining the rule
of law to stay in power and I'm not
talking about Hungary I'm not talking
about Poland I'm talking about the
country that is now the rotating chair
of the council so please listen to the
SOS for millions of Spanish citizens
European citizens I would ask you that
you should think about acting on this
you can't say we haven't warned you one
minute
president
thank you madam president when taking
stock of the commission's action you
talk about Europe's strength but the
reality seems to be a far from what is
discussed in this hemicycle a recent
survey showed that 20 of French people
can't make ends meet at the end of the
month there are people across Europe
going hungry
eating fewer meals to make sure that
they can make ends meet people
struggling to pay their energy bills but
despite this the commission has simply
multiplied the red tape Weighing on
citizens the new rules for energy
efficient buildings that's going to make
things more difficult than you farm to
Fork strategy is going to lead to a hike
in food prices and there are other
measures as well you talked at length
about power you talked about wind
turbines but you didn't say a single
word about nuclear though this is a key
source of accessible energy in Europe
you talk about cutting back on red tape
but red tape has simply increased over
the past few years all of these
constraints serve to make us more
dependent on other countries across the
world weren't facing the same
constraints we'll be turning to China to
buy our electric vehicles and we won't
be able to push for the recovery of our
economy unless we have uh less we try to
seek better education opportunities for
our young people rather than pushing for
qualified migration as you said our role
is to support families and not continue
to further destabilize our countries we
need to lean on the talents the skills
of our citizens and our countries in
order to get back to the prosperity and
the strength of our continent but for
this to be the case we're going to need
to keep our eyes open thank you I keep
saying one minute but I'm not doing very
well
thank you madam president
Madam president of the commission
Mr Vasquez in this chamber we're having
a debate on State of Union not the
disastrous state of your respective
parties and
the elections
we've shown solidarity in overcoming
crises over the last years and the
European Union has become strengthened
despite what the far right is saying the
European Union has felt protected
citizens are asking for more Europe less
nationalism we've moved towards the
health union we've overcome the taboo of
common debt to rebuild our societies
faced with the war of Putin we've also
moved towards an energy Union and open
strategic autonomy
now
for because of the Spanish presidency we
should have a migration pact on
irregular migration and regular
migration which we need we've managed to
strengthen gender equality and protect
the planet particularly with the
regulation on nature restoration I do
hope Madam that you will manage to
ensure that the Epp can in fact move
away from the hands of the far right and
move back to the normal European Center
presidential law said that when the
president and the commission go hand in
hand then the building of Europe works
properly let's hope that that's the case
and we can do that under the Spanish
president Lee let's move forward
together thank you Gaelic I've been sick
for one minute
president
economic Trends in Europe are moving in
a dangerous Direction lower
Energy prices fewer less red tape and
the like make other markets more
appealing for European companies looking
to invest even smes are exploring fresh
investment elsewhere
and it is High Time therefore that we
talk about Europe's competitiveness
otherwise the green deal is doomed to
failure it needs to be implemented with
greater economic Mouse by the way
president
you talked about measures for industrial
transformation and the SME relief
package I welcome those announcements we
cannot allow industry leave industry in
the Lurch because if industry is strong
then we'll all do well only next one
minute
thank you president
unfortunately I have to say that I was
not won over by your speech
I suspect that citizens will look feel
quite helpless we hear a few
announcements shortly before the
elections how is all this to be
implemented nothing tangible for
citizens in these difficult times you
say you've implemented 90 of your agenda
but there are some failures there women
in
um on boards why did that fail were
because of the cducu in Germany well it
was being blocked for so long and now
finally that impasse has been broken
thanks to the new government in Germany
and you said nothing about far-right
extremism that is a real shame because
we see them come to the power in many
more uh governments in Europe and that's
because your party is involved in those
coalitions we see that social rights are
being eroded access to abortion for
example
the Epp is sabotaging the European green
deal your Flagship project who will win
out at the end of the day well our
position is clear we need an
economically strong uh social Europe and
environmentally friendly Europe and
that's what we'll be focusing on thank
you
foreign thank you very much Madam
president for your leadership
perseverance competence
which
help all of the citizens of the European
Union the member states didn't want 93
billion euros under the rrf
until the 31st of August of this year
and my question is whether the European
commission is actually prepared to allow
us to reuse These funds for example to
reinforce strategic autonomy in the
European Union for example for the
Strategic investment platform step
the step platform we mustn't lose these
resources and then when it comes to
energy it's vital that Portugal should
not in fact be left on its own we need
interconnections it's vital that energy
and interconnections uh it should exist
and should go through the Pyrenees in
particular in conclusion Portugal can't
be an island when it comes to Railways
either again interconnections are
necessary throughout the Iberian
Peninsula and the rest of Europe none of
that has been finished
but let's think towards Europe in 2030
will this have been concluded by then I
don't think so and we cannot in fact
allow that to happen I hope that the
European commission will help us to
solve any problems we have with Spain
and ensuring that this all comes to pass
properly thank you
president president
Wonderland
uh that you will be able to answer the
call of History only if it's able to get
rid of the blackmail of nationalisms
which are placing a veto on the future
of our new generations the pandemic the
wars and our ports climate change all of
this has pushed Europe to respond in
unity with Extraordinary Measures to
move on from emergencies but reacting is
no longer enough we need a Europe that's
going to be able to think ahead and be
proactive
we ought to make Next Generation EU
permanent and have a real federal budget
for our Union for economic governance
this would help us to push for fair
sustainable growth we need to act with
courage in order to place extraordinary
technology at the service of human
beings such as artificial intelligence
we mustn't be intimidating president
Wonderland don't let yourself be
intimidated by the political forces some
of them close to you that are trying to
bury the European rules that we need to
save our planet at the upcoming
elections there'll be those who know how
to respond to the call of History how to
answer it and there'll be others who are
putting forward excuses and pointing the
finger at stapegoats and the Europeans
already know who they ought to be
placing their trust in thank you Maya
one minute
thank you madam president in my comments
I want to focus on economy it took a big
part of your speech very good speech and
I guess this is big if not Central issue
we are not facing the problem with high
unemployment we are facing different
programs this low income and big
uncertainty and this must be addressed I
guess it's fair to say that European
economy is lagging behind the best in
many fields we have to do something with
that despite of the fact that we are
doing well in some others I guess it's
right time to call someone like Mario
draghi who is best suited to to do
really good
situation and member states and
politicians must listen to him and act
it's almost late concerning the
initiatives I can just appreciate what
you said wind energy key for cheap and
available Energy red tapes for SME
absolutely essential because they are
costing us the growth and their the
prosperity and as well the other topics
that you have mentioned are a very
important for example uh
promoting fair trade and not allowing
the others undermined through through
unfair sex subsidies so I hope we will
act and we will act quickly because time
is running thank you thank you very much
ludek Ivan stefanet one minute
dear Madam president thank you for your
wise words I also do believe that after
many crises EU is stronger than before
and also it is thanks to your leadership
to the fast action also our ability to
cooperate nowadays many countries want
to join EU and we know that ukrainians
are even dying for this goal our
European response to the criminal
Russian aggression was strong and we
should continue with this approach
uh be significantly limited Russian
income from EU but still there is gas
and nuclear fuel which should be
included into sanctions
Madam president I was really very
pleased with your words about making
business easier and with the objective
to reduce administrative burden by 25
percent we need to do it for our smes
and for our competitiveness but still
there is one more goal which should be
achieved and this is completion of our
single Market this objective does not
require any resources just it requires
political will and it is feasible and
achievable and it is the same with for
example energy Union defense Union
Capital Market Union and I do believe
also that the Improvement of our
competitiveness will result in the
Improvement of quality of life of all
citizens thank you very much
one minutes
thank you president commission president
you said that we need to deliver today
and prepare for the future in particular
we need to strengthen our
competitiveness I can only agree with
that
I appreciate the acknowledgment you
expressed today for our Farmers as well
in the European union we need reform we
see the economic figures they are clear
we see the economic uh what the economy
wobble we see weaker budgets and
households struggling to make ends meet
we need to do everything within our
power to strengthen our economy to
ensure that value is created here in
Europe in member states
honorable members as many have said we
need deregulation we need to cut down on
red tape
ease the regulatory Borden burden and I
welcome the announcement to come in
October and finally we need to look
after our own security we need a common
European Vision
for space Maritime critical
infrastructure and cyber
those are the lessons that we honorable
members can learn from the appalling war
in Ukraine I I will give the floor to
whoever from each group has asked for
the floor first so we start with
Michaela and then Margarita Marquez
um
commission president
dear Ursula I would like to thank you
for your courageous approach and
realistic approach
realistic Solutions are precisely what
we need we need to ensure the
competitiveness of the European Union
including its smes
we need to put an end to cheap Imports
the time our companies we need to ease
the regulatory burden you have a crystal
clear proposal we need to be brave in
our vision and realistic in the way we
Implement measures now you
have talked about children being
deported from the Ukraine to Russia you
said that you will convene or would like
to convene a large conference designed
to help to get these children back to
Ukraine I would like to ask you whether
you will continue to act on that front
thank you
thank you madam president I'd like to
start by expressing my thanks to Madame
vandelion for having rework called the
results of policies of the European
Union over the last four years there
have been many of them and they result
from strong inter-institutional
cooperation and Joint work undertaken by
the European commission and the European
Parliament
we have got the creation of shore Next
Generation EU and now we have to look to
think
to what extent what we have already
created can be better used in the future
but I would point out some of the gaps
in your speech today first of all a
revision of the multi-annual budget of
the European Union and in particular we
have to think we can't have new
enlargement unless we change the
budgetary architecture of the EU second
Gap no reference to revising the
economic governance rules now we know
that we'll only manage to continue to
support investment and to support
European citizens if speaker has been
cut off
thank you madam president matsola
commissions president commission
president first of all as a Romanian MEP
and as a proud European I would like to
thank you thank you
for stating
once again that Romania and Bulgaria
belong in the Schengen area Jean-Claude
juncker in 2017 gave a speech in this
chamber he also supported Romania's
accession at that time and six years
have gone by in the meantime
unfortunately Romanian and Bulgarian
citizens are losing hope that this goal
will be delivered on Mrs funderline
Romanian Bulgaria must become members of
the Schengen area by the end of the year
otherwise it will be too late for you
and for us all
for all those of us who cherish
a belief in this project and worked
tirelessly day in day out on the
European project thank you and after
that is
thank you madam president Madame
Wonderland you said several times that
you were attached to the green deal
but you did not say a single thing about
animal welfare and revising European
rules on Animal Welfare yet this is one
of the parts of the green deal that's
been most eagerly expected by European
citizens this reform uh is supposed to
be part of the commission's commitment
to moving forward on this after Farm to
Fork
and there was a year and a half of
legislative work on improving Animal
Welfare following this the citizen
initiative and the Cage age
this reform were it to be carried
forward or rather were it to be halted
in that would deal a blow to The
commission's credibility
you cannot hide behind false arguments
such as inflation if we really want to
drive down inflation there are other
ways to do that
for instance look at the margins uh
wheeled in some Industries animals are
not to pay the price in the service of
political calculations a few months out
from the elections and we're counting on
you thank you
foreign
latinum president of the commission I'd
like to ask about what you're planning
to do about Animal Welfare
there's a copy in November but the Press
are indicating that Animal Welfare
legislation could be delayed until the
next commission comes into Force after
the European elections so I'd like to
know whether in fact we are going to
repeal existing legislation I hope like
many citizens that we are to cover all
areas of Animal Welfare we have the
European citizens initiatives and the
Cage age and animal experimentation all
of these have been successful Animal
Welfare is an important subject for
European citizens is it a an important
subject for you madam vandelion
277.
go ahead
microphone
and now I see what it means to live in a
brussel bubble this is where your speech
comes from on the other hand we have
concrete numbers and reality which shows
that the European economy is in a very
bad situations that the prices of energy
are higher than ever that many parts of
Europe's uh Europe are crashing under
large migrations this will have
consequences not only on the economy but
on our future
and the situation relating to democracy
is not as you want to present in
European uh elections we have have the
turnout then on national elections which
means that people don't believe in
democracy we believe not you believe in
ideology in green ideologies and other
Concepts this is the state of the nation
and only people can change this but new
people
foreign
thank you commission president
you were very eloquent in expressing
your disdain for the working classes in
Europe I know that you earn 30 000 a
month do you know that today in Europe
30 of people have to skip a meal because
they don't have enough money to eat
three meals a day 46 percent of
Europeans are afraid to turn up the
heating they shiver in the cold 100
million people are at risk of poverty
and what is your stock taking exercise
well did you put a cap on energy bills
did you Levy taxes on millionaires
Surplus profits made by energy military
and pharmaceutical multinationals what
are you doing here today well you are
guaranteeing Millions for the military
sector arms multinationals
returned to the budgetary packed and
austerity Mrs Van Der Lyon this Europe
your Europe will never be ours we will
fight you and your Coalition tooth and
nail thank you Mr castaldo apologies to
all the members who could not take the
floor now we had just too many requests
thank you chair Madam president I would
like to express my heartfelt thanks to
you for your Clarity and courage today
your right history is calling for a
geopolitical union to diligently protect
our companies and workers from deceptive
trade practices subsidies and dumping
employed by China none of our member
states as the size The Strand to nor the
authority to safeguard our technological
industrial sovereignty in isolation what
has happened in recent years
demonstrates this conclusively selling
to the public opinion on the opposite at
this juncture is much more than
recklessly naive similarly failing to
publicly and inequivocally condemn the
Intolerable crimes against humanity
repetited by Russia against Ukrainian
people is an act of profound hypocrisy
no Pursuit of fleeting easy electoral
consensus can justify immoral silences
and ambiguities our duty extends far
beyond the next election she decompasses
the well-being of future generation of
Europeans a commitment I will continue
to uphold no matter the risks yes we
must combine enlargement with political
deepening yes we must create another
great budget financed by permanent
common debt to protect our European
common goods and yes we must implement
the necessary treaty changes and launch
a real European bottom-up Casino thank
you Fabio Massimo
I give the floor now to the commission
president for five minutes
to reply thank you
thank you very much honorable members
Madam president
many of you
described where we came from
the double mission that we had at the
very beginning in 2019 the green and the
digital transition then came a virus
then came the atrocious Russian war
against Ukraine
and I was glad to hear many of you
comment that Europe managed to be strong
and agile
and we will not rest Malik we will keep
up the high ambition
rest assure for that so the main
messages of today are certainly first of
all we are living an uncertain world
without any doubt but Europe will deal
with it be it the Russian war
be it climate change be it how to keep
AI human-centric
the second message is we are preparing
the EU economy for the future
so that the clean industry made in
Europe is here at home
that we will address
the lack of skilled labor that we will
cut red tape
the third point is of course on
enlargement and the because I heard you
let me which is a bit funny quote myself
from the speech as us gave
this is not a question of deepening
integration or widening the union we can
and must do both
and the second point is that I always
will support this house and all of those
who want to reform the EU and make it
work better for Citizens and yes
that means including through a European
convention and treaty change event where
needed but we cannot wait
till we have done this treaty change to
move ahead with enlargement that was the
message of the speech
finally a strong message that we have to
strengthen our democracy that's a daily
work because they are never perfect but
they are perfectable and this is our
task so thank you for very Lively Rich
discussion with support and criticism
with ideas and warnings this is the
beauty of democracy that this is
possible to do all this and this is what
democracies do they answer to the
aspirations and the anxieties of their
citizens by action
so for us it is important that in this
electoral year we must continue to be
active that this is a year of action
thank you very much for your tireless
engagement
and I am looking forward to the months
to come
there are lots of uncertainties
but one thing is for sure Long Live
Europe thank you thank you very much
president Wonderland
everybody one minute
foreign
Ty and being increasingly influenced by
foreign powers over the past decade
Asian countries especially China have
been dominating many Manufacturing
Technologies that are absolutely crucial
for our economy and without which our
economy wouldn't even exist the list of
these Technologies includes chip and
Battery manufacturing the U.S has
already realized that its economy is too
exposed to China in terms of these
Technologies and it is taking the
necessary counter measures China began
gaining influence in Europe as well but
the EU has no response to it whatsoever
in fact it hasn't even recognized the
problem
for example uh they take certain
measures with respect to the automobile
economy and the situation is even worse
there are some EU member states for
example Hungary whose governments are
acting as throwing horses to Aid
economically hostile powers in gaining
influence at the expense of the European
interest thus undermining our
continent's common future it's time for
Europe to protect itself
go ahead
Madame La president president
Madam president I listen closely to your
speech and I've got to say that I was
pretty taken aback at how completely far
removed from reality you seem to be it's
time to come down from the Ivory Tower
you say we've got to answer the call of
History
but there's one call you're not
answering the call of a third of
Europeans who aren't having who don't
have enough to eat because of inflation
and you manage the exploit of not saying
a single word about them today
so you seem to be refusing to hear our
call for an emergency social plan that
would be financed by the richest Among
Us and super prophets I'm going to do
something that's not very frequent in
the European Parliament I'm going to
give the floor to a European citizen one
of the ones you didn't listen to will be
very quick
every evening we go to bed hungry and
unfortunately the sound has been cut off
yes
and there are millions of people like
this in the European Union they're the
ones you ought to be taking action for
imagined
you want to see the poor the poppers
turning to you for soccer but my
impression today Madame Wonderland is
that you don't want to send sucker to
anyone there'll be no help for anyone so
you can count on our group we'll
continue to keep fighting to ensure that
help is given to those who need it most
thank you
thank you madam president from this
debate without any doubt there is some
positive news we'll take away with us
it's the last
that we have from unfunder line so
there'll be a better future for Europe I
would reiterate what's been said this
isn't a time for committees for working
groups for special envoys we know what
the problems are and what we need are
tangible Speedy responses and those are
what we expect from the commission a
revision of the green deal because this
transition needs to be genuinely just we
need a radically different approach to
immigration particularly illegal
immigration which should be called that
and on autonomy we need genuine tangible
responses not bureaucracy doing less
better should be the guideline for what
the commission does over coming months
this
is
thank you president well let's compare
your words to the facts you talked about
the rule of law but in fact the European
commission frequently violates uh
treaties infringing on the rights of
member states now when it comes to
competition
and the green deal
well the green deal has placed never
higher burden on European businesses
businesses of every nature and when it
comes to migration policy well there's a
migration crisis on
with thousands of migrants arriving just
yesterday in lampedusa
but European solidarity isn't just
rooted in words in fact it's rooted in
Deeds
in two days time
the ban on Ukrainian green will be
lifted but you're aiming to extend this
uh I would I would solidarity to polish
Farmers thank you we share your ID that
indeed we need to deepen and to widen
the European Union but we cannot use
that as an excuse to keep people waiting
longer than needed it has to be married
based but married based only merit-based
now the thing is if Ukraine would join
today all 27 member states except one
would be net contributors to the new
budget I hope that this will make member
states realize that we need the European
Union to be funded by its own resources
and I hope it will Dawn upon them that
that's the only way to keep it going but
you know and well we can do that without
3D revision you know and I will quote
Vladimir Ilitch Lenin when there's the
will there's a way thank you
Mercy
thank you madam president
well Mr Lombards always has excellent
timely quotations I'd like to start by
thanking everyone that spoke
and my colleagues from the empty s and
Ian greens mentioned the end of the
Mandate and being useful in terms of the
last texts
that we'll be voting on air quality for
example
we need majorities and we need an
ambitious approach Madam president
you'll have understood we want to be
useful in the next nine months remaining
and clearly the whole question of energy
the question of immigration those are
our priorities at some point we're going
to have to also discuss the institutions
and the way in which we can reinforce
the powers of parliament clearly I
didn't mention that if there's a time to
speak of Institutions not now maybe but
if we keep delaying reform if we keep
delaying our decision making processes
in Europe becoming more rapid then we're
going to lose political Effectiveness so
Madam president ambition has to be the
key word for the next nine months
clearly and then there's the whole
question of democracy as I said in my
speech is vital and the rule of law will
always be the DNA of my group thank you
and let me thank you president
the slogan of Europe United in diversity
is more meaningful than ever today with
this debate I've heard some statements
that I frankly find greatly worrying so
let me just clarify something here the
best way to defend the rule of law is to
accept the Democratic results coming
from the polls
this poses no threat to a country this
is a government pushing for a social
progress to push up pensions calling for
a dialogue for living together
peacefully those who are working to
break up the unity of a country are
those who call for a citizen Rebellion
against the Democratic results of the
ballot the Socialists are going to keep
working we're going to keep working to
live together side by side to keep
working for understanding dialogue and
for a stronger Europe because the
history of Europe always ends well thank
you thank you and finally Francis
Fitzgerald
president who stressed the need to
answer the call for history this
Parliament will do just that
the challenges are greater than ever as
we all know and was Illustrated in the
debate here this morning that's why
Europe needs to be ambitious that's why
I welcome your proposals on leading the
world in artificial intelligence wind
energy strengthening our security and
crucially working to enlarge our Union
to include our Eastern Partners
including Ukraine that's why Europe
needs to be competitive that's why we
must reduce red tape on business that's
why Europe must stay open for business
strategic autonomy must not mean
protectionism subsidies and trade
barriers that's why Europe needs to put
people first that's why your words and
combating violence this morning are
vital you were right no means no you
have done outstanding work on gender
equality but this must become a legal
reality across all the member states and
they must examine their approach to the
inclusion of rape in the director from
violence against women we have free
movement but we do not have common
protections against violence for women
there can be no true equality without
freedom from violence thank you
thank you very much to you to everybody
the debate is now closed we will suspend
for two minutes and we will resume with
the formal address by Mr Atlanta and
then the votes so please
stay in the room
thanks a lot
thank you